Denise Clark is a retired schoolteacher who still works as a substitute. When COVID hit and her high school switched to remote learning, it was hard for her for all the normal reasons. But also, like lots of older people, she wasn't so great on computers. Ditto for her friend, Pearl, who was another substitute at that school, who Denise would do crossword puzzles with in the faculty lounge.
丹尼斯·克拉克是一位退休的学校老师，现在仍担任代课老师。当新冠疫情爆发，她所在的高中转向远程教学时，由于种种常见的原因，这对她来说非常困难。但和许多老年人一样，她不太擅长使用电脑。她的朋友珀尔也是那所学校的代课老师，丹尼斯常在教职员工休息室和她一起做填字游戏，情况也是如此。
Pearl, also not so great on the computers. And Pearl was a decade older than Denise, in her mid-70s.
珀尔也不太擅长电脑。而且珀尔比丹尼斯大十岁，已经70多岁了。
She always told me, can you help me? She thought I was good at it, so she always wanted me to help her. I really wasn't the best person. It took a while for me to learn it, to tell you the truth.
她总是对我说，你能帮帮我吗？她觉得我擅长这个，所以总是想让我帮她。说实话，我真的不是最擅长的人。我花了一段时间才学会。
You know, you think, if you're 75, and your job completely changes, you might call it quits. But Pearl was adamant. She was going to learn to work on the computer. And when she got stuck, she wasn't shy to call in help from the IT guy, or the assistant principal, or really, whoever she could find.
你想想，如果你75岁了，工作完全变了，你可能就辞职了。但珀尔很坚决。她一定要学会用电脑。当她遇到困难时，她从不羞于向IT人员、副校长或是她能找到的任何人求助。
I had to tip my hat to her if I had one. Because she would keep trying. That's the thing I like about her. She'd ask questions. She was doing better than some of us. [LAUGHS]
如果我戴着帽子，我一定要向她致敬。因为她会不断尝试。这就是我喜欢她的地方。她会问问题。她做得比我们中的一些人还要好。[笑]
And Pearl, she kept up with it. You know, she didn't know sometimes-- she had some difficulties.
而珀尔，她坚持了下来。你知道，虽然她有时会不知道怎么做——她遇到了一些困难。
What kind of difficulties was she having?
她遇到了什么样的困难？
Well, we all had difficulties. You know, we had to get-- to get in. Sometimes the computer's lights would go off. But this was new-- the Zoom stuff. But you had to learn it.
嗯，我们都有困难。你知道，我们得设法——登录。有时电脑屏幕会变黑。但这些都是新鲜事物——那些Zoom之类的。但你必须得学会。
Pearl did learn it. Pearl's daughter, Pam, in fact, told me that she watched, fascinated that her 70-something-year-old mom was on the computer all the time.
珀尔确实学会了。事实上，珀尔的女儿帕姆告诉我，她看着自己70多岁的母亲一直在电脑前忙碌，感到非常惊讶。
Over a year before this, she'd bought Pearl a laptop that had mostly gone unused. But now, Pearl was running a classroom on Zoom, taking attendance, telling kids to get on camera and participate.
在此之前一年多，她给珀尔买了一台笔记本电脑，基本没怎么用过。但现在，珀尔在用Zoom管理课堂，进行考勤，叫孩子们打开摄像头参与互动。
I always tell her how proud I was of her for that.
我总是告诉她，我为她感到骄傲。
And after that achievement-- OK, who would have guessed that this was going to happen-- Pearl started using her computer and her phone when she was not working, in ways that her daughter had never imagined were possible.
在那之后，谁能想到会发生这样的事——珀尔开始在工作之余使用电脑和手机，方式超出了她女儿的想象。
She never-- my mom never sent me an email. But when she got on Facebook-- oh my goodness.
她以前从没——我妈妈从来没给我发过电子邮件。但当她上了Facebook之后——天哪。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
She started communicating through Facebook all the time.
她开始通过Facebook和人频繁交流。
So there was some day where, like, you're on Facebook, and then suddenly, your mom pops up? And were you just like, what's happening?
所以有没有哪天，比如你正在刷Facebook，突然你妈妈跳出来了？你当时是什么感觉，心想发生了什么？
Oh, yeah. Oh my gosh, OK, so all of a sudden, my mom is coming up in my Timelines. Like, if I put a picture up of, you know, me and my daughters going out to eat somewhere, then I would get something on Facebook saying, you didn't invite me, you know, and things like that, you know? Oh, yeah, it would be funny sometimes.
哦，是的。天哪，突然之间，我妈妈出现在我的动态里。比如，如果我发了一张我和女儿们出去吃饭的照片，我就会在Facebook上收到评论说，你没邀请我，诸如此类的话。哦，是的，有时候真的很有趣。
If she couldn't get in contact with me or Damon-- that's my younger brother--
如果她联系不上我或者戴蒙——那是我的弟弟——
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
--she knows that if she would put on Facebook, tell Pam or tell Damon to call me, someone in our family is calling us to say, you know, call your mom.
——她知道只要发到Facebook上，让帕姆或戴蒙给我打电话，我们家里的某个人就会打来电话说，嘿，给你妈回个电话。
On Saturday, May 14, Pam's mom, Pearl, was one of the 10 people killed at Tops grocery in Buffalo. A teenage white supremacist has been charged with driving over three hours there to murder Black people. When something like the Buffalo shooting happens, each of the people killed gets summarized afterwards in a sentence. Pearl was Pearl Young, the 77-year-old grandmother who taught Sunday school and ran a food pantry at the church for decades.
5月14日星期六，帕姆的母亲珀尔是在布法罗Tops超市遇难的10人之一。一名十几岁的白人至上主义者被指控开车三个多小时赶到那里杀害黑人。当布法罗枪击案这类事件发生时，每一位遇难者随后都会被用一句话概括。珀尔就是珀尔·杨，那位77岁的祖母，她几十年来一直在教堂教主日学校并负责运营食物银行。
That leaves so much out about how she lived-- big things, like special connections she had with teenagers, how they'd bond with her, and could talk to her about what was really going on with them; little things, like how her world changed when she learned the computer and started mildly trolling her grown children on Facebook. We're all of us too big to fit into a sentence.
这句话省略了她生活中的太多东西——大事，比如她与青少年之间建立的特殊联系，他们如何与她交心，向她倾诉真实的想法；小事，比如当她学会电脑后，世界发生了怎样的改变，以及她如何在Facebook上轻微地“调侃”她已成年的孩子们。我们所有人都太复杂了，绝非一句话能概括。
Take Aaron Salter Jr., who was also killed at Tops that day. The story about him that was repeated a lot in the wake of the shooting-- he was a store security guard, a retired police officer. And when the gunman came in firing a semiautomatic rifle, Aaron Salter exchanged fire with him. But the guy was wearing body armor, and killed Aaron Salter.
再看看那天同样在Tops遇害的亚伦·萨尔特。枪击案发生后，关于他的故事被反复讲述——他是一名超市保安，一名退休警察。当枪手持半自动步枪闯入开火时，亚伦·萨尔特曾与之交火。但那个人穿着防弹衣，杀害了亚伦·萨尔特。
He was called a hero. There were photos of him in his uniform. But there were other sides to him. In his spare time, Salter would invent things. He was a tinkerer-- rebuilt a '67 Cadillac.
人们称他为英雄。有很多他穿着制服的照片。但他还有其他的一面。在业余时间，萨尔特喜欢搞发明。他是个巧手——重组了一辆67年的凯迪拉克。
In 2011, when gas prices rose to over $4 a gallon, he went online and bought plans to refit a car engine so it would run on water by splitting the water into hydrogen and oxygen, and using that hydrogen as fuel. Like any hobbyist, there are videos of him talking about this online, getting those original plans.
2011年，当汽油价格涨到每加仑超过4美元时，他上网购买了改造汽车引擎的方案，试图通过将水分解成氢气和氧气，并利用氢气作为燃料来运行汽车。像任何业余爱好者一样，网上有他谈论这个项目、获取最初方案的视频。
I was skeptical myself. I didn't-- you know, I didn't believe that it would work. But I just wanted to see.
我自己曾持怀疑态度。我——你知道，我不相信这行得通。但我只是想看看。
He says the plans that he bought online, they weren't any good. So he designed his own version with a cooling system and a circulation system, and it worked-- a little, anyway.
他说他网上买的方案不好。于是他设计了自己的版本，带有一个冷却系统和一个循环系统，而且确实起作用了——至少起了一点作用。
All right, I'm just going to-- I'm just going to start it.
好了，我准备要——我要启动它了。
[CAR STARTING]
[汽车启动声]
His system, which he built and installed in an F-150 truck, was innovative enough that it was actually granted a patent. And Salter says in these videos that he's been able to drive the truck on hydrogen for 8/10 of a mile so far, though in the videos, it all very much still looks like a work in progress. Like, after he throws the valve to send hydrogen into the engine, it runs for a little while, but then he has to shut it down.
他的系统被安装在一辆福特F-150卡车上，创新性足以让他获得专利。萨尔特在视频中说，他目前已经能用氢气驱动卡车行驶了0.8英里，尽管在视频中，这看起来仍然是个半成品。比如，在他打开阀门将氢气送入引擎后，它能运行一小会儿，但随后他就不得不将其关闭。
[ENGINE WINDING DOWN]
[引擎熄火声]
It's holding water.
里面有水。
It's holding water in it?
里面有水吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
Water pours out of the tube that's supposed to be carrying only hydrogen.
水从本应只输送氢气的管子里流了出来。
And that's not supposed to be there, right?
那不应该出现在那里，对吧？
That's why it's not running.
这就是它无法运行的原因。
Watching him troubleshoot on these videos is where it really starts to feel like you see Aaron Salter's personality for the first time. He's calm, methodical.
看着他在这些视频里排除故障，你才第一次真正感觉到亚伦·萨尔特的个性。他冷静、有条不紊。
Got to get this water.
得把这些水弄走。
His son, Aaron III, told a reporter after he died that the last time he saw his dad, they went riding motorcycles. And when his motorcycle broke down, and his dad got into the engine to try to fix it, it was the most Aaron Salter Junior-y thing his dad could have done. Just seeing him in action, he said, doing stuff like that, is what I'm going to miss about him.
他的儿子亚伦三世在父亲去世后告诉记者，他最后一次见到父亲时，他们去骑摩托车。当他的摩托车坏了，父亲钻进引擎试图修理时，那是他父亲能做的最“亚伦·萨尔特”的事了。他说，看着他行动起来，做这些事情，就是我最想念他的地方。
[MUSIC - CURTIS LOVELL]
[音乐 - 柯蒂斯·洛弗尔]
Well, today on our program, this has been a year of so many mass shootings, really horrific ones, that it feels hard to absorb the names and pictures of each one before the next one happens. Uvalde was, I don't know, what was it, 10 days after Buffalo? What happened in Buffalo was a mass shooting, but it was also an act of racial violence.
今天在我们的节目中，这一年发生了太多的大规模枪击案，真的非常骇人，以至于在下一起发生之前，都很难消化每一个人的名字和照片。尤瓦尔迪案，我不知道，那是在布法罗案之后10天？布法罗发生的是一起大规模枪击案，但同时也是一种种族暴力行为。
The alleged killer wrote in his 180-page manifesto, his whole goal was, quote, "to kill as many Blacks as possible." That's how he chose Tops. He didn't care in particular who they were, just that they were Black.
那位涉嫌杀手在他180页的宣言中写道，他的全部目标就是，引用他的话，“尽可能多地杀害黑人”。这就是他选择Tops的原因。他并不在乎他们具体是谁，只要他们是黑人就行。
What do you do in the face of that? Well, I think first and foremost, it seems worth asserting the obvious fact that these were not interchangeable Black people, but specific people living their lives, and that we remember them for who they were, as well as we know how. At our show, we were talking about that list of names that went around after Buffalo, 10 names and ages, and what it would mean to know more about them and tell some of their stories in ways that we hadn't heard before after one of these shootings.
面对这种情况你能做什么？嗯，我认为首先，很有必要申明一个显而易见的事实：这些人并不是可以随意替代的黑人，而是有着具体生活的人，我们要尽我们所能去记住他们。在我们的节目中，我们谈论了布法罗事件后流传的那份名单，10个名字和年龄，我们想知道更多关于他们的事，并以一种我们之前从未听过的方式讲述他们的一些故事。
We asked a bunch of Black writers to use their skills to help us do just that. Each one wrote about somebody they felt some connection to, or noticed some detail about that they couldn't get out of their head, to show you a side of these 10 people that you have not heard or seen. That's our show today. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们邀请了一群黑人作家利用他们的笔触来帮我们完成这件事。每个人都写了一个他们感到有某种共鸣，或者捕捉到了某个让他们难以忘怀的细节的人，向你展示这10个人你不曾听说或见过的一面。这就是我们今天的节目。来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
The music that you're hearing right now is by Curtis Lovell, a Buffalo musician who you're going to hear throughout the show today. And let's start with--
你现在听到的音乐来自柯蒂斯·洛弗尔，一位布法罗的音乐家，你今天将在节目中一直听到她的作品。让我们从——
Celestine Chaney, 65 years old. The one-sentence description of her was something like, she attended Fosdick-Masten Vocational High School, which was a prestigious school for girls in Buffalo, where she studied to be a seamstress, went on to jobs in Buffalo companies that made suits and baseball caps. Though in reading about her, we saw a thing where one of her grandchildren, a 25-year-old, Kayla Jones, said her grandmother was her best friend, and they were really close, somebody that she could confide in over homemade margaritas. They'd party together.
塞莱斯廷·钱尼，65岁。对她的一句话描述大概是这样的：她就读于福斯迪克-马斯顿职业高中，那是布法罗一所著名的女子学校，她在那里学习缝纫，后来在布法罗制作西装和棒球帽的公司工作。然而在阅读关于她的资料时，我们发现她的一个孙女，25岁的凯拉·琼斯说，她的祖母是她最好的朋友，她们非常亲密，是可以一起喝自制玛格丽特酒、分享心事的伙伴。她们会一起聚会。
Writer Brittany Luse was interested in that relationship and talked to Kayla.
作家布列塔尼·卢斯对这种关系很感兴趣，并采访了凯拉。
Kayla Jones says most of the words you'd use to describe a grandma apply to hers, Celestine Chaney. She could sew, was active in church, and loved to host. The family would often get together at Celestine's place for parties-- like, real parties.
凯拉·琼斯说，大多数用来描述祖母的词都适用于她的祖母塞莱斯廷·钱尼。她会缝纫，在教堂很活跃，而且喜欢招待客人。家人们经常在塞莱斯廷家聚会——那是真正的聚会。
Grandma had a bar. Like, she used to-- like, at her house, a lot of people would come over for-- like, they'd have game night. You know, our game nights be like, Uno and stuff.
奶奶有个吧台。就像，她曾经——在她的房子里，很多人会来玩——比如游戏之夜。你知道，我们的游戏之夜通常玩Uno之类的。
But their game nights is, like, gambling with card games and stuff like that. And they had bingo. So that's why they-- like, a lot of her sisters and her cousins and stuff, they'd come over and they'd do all that. They got a bar.
但她们的游戏之夜是赌博，玩纸牌游戏之类的。还有宾果。所以这就是为什么——很多她的姐妹和表亲会过来一起玩。她们有吧台。
The thing Kayla connected most with her grandma about? They both liked to look good-- nails, hair, clothes. Celestine refused to leave the house looking anything less than immaculate. She and Kayla shared that in common. Of course, they had different ideas about what immaculate looked like.
凯拉和祖母最紧密的联系是什么？她们都喜欢打扮得漂漂亮亮——指甲、头发、衣服。塞莱斯廷出门时总是拒绝让自己看起来不整洁。她和凯拉有共同点。当然，她们对“整洁”的定义不同。
Kayla says her grandma would tease her for showing too much skin. Celestine preferred to shop at Kohl's and Burlington Coat Factory.
凯拉说祖母会取笑她穿得太露。塞莱斯廷更喜欢在Kohl's和伯灵顿折扣店购物。
She always at the nail shop whenever she needed a fill. She wore acrylics, so-- never nothing too long. She was always like the oval. I can say, like, short, not too short length.
她每次需要补做美甲时总是会去指甲店。她做的是亚克力指甲，——从不过长。她总是喜欢椭圆形的。我可以说是短的，不是太短的那种。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
And she got the little-- always used to have, like, the back in the day nail tech-- like, you know, back in the day, the styles we used to get? Like, she still got those, like, with the little lines and dots and stuff like that.
她总是做那种——那种老式的指甲设计——就像，你知道，以前我们常做的款式？比如，她还是喜欢那些有小线条和点点的设计。
With the lines and dots on the little palm tree.
带线条和点点的小棕榈树。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, like we used to wear early 2000s. She still gets that style.
对，对，对，就像我们在2000年代初常戴的那样。她依然保留着那种风格。
Celestine reminds me a lot of my own mom. They're both loving grandmothers, church ladies who like to party, and they both love a full look. They were also both born in the 1950s. Many Black women of that generation were taught that chipped nails, undone hair, or wrinkly clothes could widen the gap between you and a job, a home loan, or basic respect. Beauty was a joy, but it was also a shield.
塞莱斯廷让我想起我自己的妈妈。她们都是慈祥的祖母，喜欢聚会的教堂女士，而且她们都追求完美妆容。她们也都是50年代出生的。那一代的许多黑人女性被教导说，指甲有缺口、头发凌乱或衣服起皱可能会拉大你与工作、房贷或基本尊重之间的距离。美是一种快乐，但也是一种防御盾牌。
When Kayla was still a kid, Celestine went through a lot with her health. She battled breast cancer and suffered three brain aneurysms. When Celestine began to lose her hair, Kayla started to style it for her.
当凯拉还是个孩子的时候，塞莱斯廷的健康经历了很多波折。她与乳腺癌抗争，还经历了三次脑动脉瘤。当塞莱斯廷开始脱发时，凯拉开始为她做发型。
They took a piece of her skull out, so I'm not sure if they was working on her brain or something like that. So she had, like, a little dent in it. And I know for sure, like, that's the worst part about it that she hated, was that, and of course because her hair had to get cut off.
医生切除了她的一部分头骨，我不确定他们是在处理她的大脑还是其他什么。所以她头上有个小凹痕。我知道那是她最讨厌的部分，当然还有因为生病不得不剪掉头发。
So, like, in that part where the dent was, the hair fairly-- like, it didn't grow as much.
所以，在有凹痕的地方，头发长得不太好。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
So like, when I used to-- like, sometimes she would wear her real hair. And I'd have to curl it. She was just like, can you please just make sure that you cover that up? Because she genuinely did not like that.
所以当我以前——有时候她会戴着真发。我得卷好。她只是说，你能确保把它遮住吗？因为她真的很不喜欢那样。
What was it like back then to be able to care for your grandmother in that way?
当时以那种方式照顾你的祖母是什么感觉？
I didn't really like it because I know she didn't like it. And I know that she feels some type of way about it. It's just sad to-- so I just did whatever I can to help out. Because I know if it was me, I would hate it, too.
我不太喜欢，因为我知道她不喜欢那样。我知道她对此感到难过。看着她那样太让人心碎了——所以我只是尽我所能提供帮助。因为我知道如果是我的话，我也会讨厌那样。
Kayla's interest in hair eventually led her to hair school. In recent years, Kayla started making wigs for her grandmother just because Celestine liked them. She'd see Kayla in her custom wigs and say, give me that wig when you're done with it.
凯拉对头发的兴趣最终让她进入了美发学校。近年来，凯拉开始为祖母做假发，只是因为塞莱斯廷喜欢。她看到凯拉戴着定制假发，就会说，你戴完之后把那顶给我。
So I can't say she had a favorite, but I did make her a couple. My favorite wig that she had was the one I made her. And it had blue streaks in it.
所以我不能说她有最喜欢的，但我确实给她做过几顶。她最喜欢的那顶是我做的。上面有蓝色的条纹。
Blue streaks?
蓝色条纹？
I gave her some blue streaks, yep. I got a picture.
我给她加了一些蓝色挑染，是的。我有照片。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Wait, so was it short, or was it long--
等等，那是短的还是长的——
It was like a short bob. I made her a short middle part bob. And I put, like, a little-- couple tracks in it, like blue tracks, like teal.
那是短波波头。我给她做了一个短的中分波波头。我加了几条蓝色发束，像是青色那种。
That's cute.
那很可爱。
And throughout the back. But she had a nice, little, wavy bob. She really liked that.
就在后脑勺位置。她留着一个漂亮的微卷波波头。她真的很喜欢那个。
I was going to say, what was her response when she saw that the wig was blue?
我正想说，当她看到假发是蓝色的时候，她的反应是什么？
She was cracking up. I got a video when I had-- she liked it. I think she liked it.
她在狂笑。我有个视频，当时我有——她很喜欢。我想她是喜欢的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
She wore it. It wasn't OD a lot of blue in it. I probably put, like, three or four tracks in so it had, like, little small streaks. Yeah, yeah, yeah, she didn't have, like, nothing too blue, too much. Something that she can definitely wear, but it's something a little extra-- you know, extra little-- she never had a little style like that. So I wanted her to stand out a little.
她戴上了。里面并没有太多蓝色。我可能只加了三四条发束，所以只是小小的条纹。对，对，对，她没有做太夸张的颜色。那是一个她绝对可以佩戴，但又带点个性的东西——你知道，额外的一点小特色——她从没试过那种风格。所以我想要她显得有点与众不同。
Celestine was a traditional lady, the type who might find a signature style and stick with it-- a press and curl, a roller set, maybe they'll do a flat iron with a little bump at the ends. But your granddaughter suggesting blue highlights? Not going to happen.
塞莱斯廷是一位传统女士，那种找到标志性风格就会坚持到底的人——卷发定型、滚筒卷发，或者用直发器拉出一点弧度。但孙女建议蓝色挑染？那是绝对不可能的。
But Celestine was loving and trusting enough of Kayla to allow herself to be seen the way her granddaughter saw her. Celestine embraced all of Kayla, exactly how she was-- mostly.
但塞莱斯廷足够爱凯拉、信任凯拉，允许自己以孙女眼中的样子被看到。塞莱斯廷接纳了凯拉的全部，无论她是什么样——大部分时候。
Just she can't stand my eyelashes, they're so long. When I do put lashes in, she'll go, I'm gonna cut them off with toenail clippers. I literally have a video of her saying that. Like, I'm going to get them-- take them little caterpillars off your eyes.
只是她受不了我的睫毛，它们太长了。当我戴假睫毛时，她会说，我要用脚趾甲剪把它剪掉。我手机里真的有个视频是她这么说的。就像，我要把那两只小毛毛虫从你眼睛上弄下来。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
That's the only thing she could not stand, was them long lashes. That's why I put some on her. I ain't OD at the funeral, but, like, when I put her together for the funeral, I did put lashes on her.
那是她唯一受不了的事情，就是那些长睫毛。这就是为什么我也给她戴了一些。葬礼的时候我没有弄得太夸张，但当我为她的葬礼整理仪容时，我确实给她戴上了睫毛。
You put lashes on her for the funeral?
你在葬礼上给她戴了睫毛？
Yeah, it was my payback.
是的，这是我的报复。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She looked cute, though. [LAUGHS]
不过她看起来很可爱。[笑]
Did you do her hair for the funeral, as well?
你为葬礼也做了她的头发吗？
Yeah, I got her a wig, like a short bob. It was a front bang wig. And then I had one of my best friends do her makeup. And then we had matching outfits. So I had-- we had the same suit on. Like, exactly the same outfit, just same suit, same undershirt.
是的，我给她准备了一顶假发，短波波头。那是一顶带齐刘海的假发。然后我请我最好的朋友帮她化了妆。我们还穿了搭配的衣服。我们穿了同样的套装，款式一模一样，内搭也一样。
Do you think your-- do you think your grandmother would be honored by that, by you all being-- like, looking so much alike on that day?
你觉得你——你觉得你的祖母会为那一天你们看起来那么像而感到荣幸吗？
Oh, of course. I made sure she went out-- like, she looked really cute. Like, she looked really good and-- because they had to do, like, a lot of-- they had to reconstruct the side of her face. So I had to just make sure, like, we could get her looking just like-- you know what I mean, to herself as possible. But she looked really good-- like, really good.
哦，当然。我确保她走的时候看起来很美——她看起来真的很棒，因为他们不得不做了很多——他们不得不重建她半边脸。所以我必须确保我们能让她看起来尽可能像她自己。但她看起来真的很好——真的很棒。
When we're little, the first, and often only people to care for our hair are family-- mothers, aunties, sisters, cousins, and grandmothers. We spend long mornings between their knees or at kitchen tables with combs and brushes next to our cereal bowls before our days even begin. Their palms kiss our scalps, allowing us to greet an unkind world with a halo of love. And sometimes, when we grow up, we have the honor of returning the gesture.
当我们小的时候，第一个，通常也是唯一一个照顾我们头发的人就是家人——母亲、阿姨、姐妹、堂姐妹和祖母。在早晨开始之前，我们会在她们的膝盖之间或是厨房的桌子旁，伴着麦片碗旁边的梳子和刷子度过很长时间。她们的手掌抚摸着我们的头皮，让我们带着爱的光环迎接这个并不总是友善的世界。有时，当我们长大后，我们有幸回馈这一举动。
Brittany Luse is co-host of the For Colored Nerds podcast.
布列塔尼·卢斯是《有色书呆子》播客的联合主持人。
Andre Mackniel, born 1969. After the Buffalo shooting, there wasn't a lot written about Andre Mackniel, and his family hasn't been talking much to the press. We know that he worked at a restaurant, had five children, that he wrote poetry. The one place that he shared parts of himself publicly was on TikTok.
安德烈·麦克尼尔，生于1969年。布法罗枪击案后，关于安德烈·麦克尼尔的报道并不多，他的家人也没有过多接受媒体采访。我们只知道他在一家餐厅工作，有五个孩子，还写诗。他唯一公开分享自己一部分生活的地方是TikTok。
Here, at our radio show, the person who swims the furthest and deepest in the ocean that is TikTok is Bim Adewunmi. She has many thoughts about what she sees there. We were very interested to hear what she would say about his videos. She likes them.
在这里，在我们的广播节目中，在TikTok这片海洋里游得最深最远的人是比姆·阿德温米。她对自己在那里看到的东西有很多想法。我们非常想听听她会如何评价他的视频。她很喜欢它们。
Andre was 53 years old when he was murdered. And he used TikTok exactly as you would expect a 53-year-old man to use TikTok, which is to say, he's not interested in recreating complex, choreographed dances. And he's not telling funny stories. We actually never hear his voice.
安德烈被害时53岁。他使用TikTok的方式正如你所预料的那样，一个53岁的男人会如何使用TikTok——也就是说，他对那种复杂的编舞舞蹈不感兴趣。他也不是在讲搞笑故事。我们甚至从未听过他的声音。
Instead, there are slideshows of friends and members of his family, or of himself, often in his car. Here's one of his partner in hospital after giving birth. Here's a smiling kid with cornrows. Here's a screenshot of a Facebook photo.
相反，他的视频里都是朋友和家人的幻灯片，或者他自己的照片，通常是在车里。这里有他伴侣生完孩子后在医院的照片。这里有个留着玉米垄发型的微笑孩子。这里有一张Facebook照片的截图。
His videos are all soundtracked by music he liked, some of it three decades old-- R&B songs by artists like Luther Vandross, Usher, Jagged Edge, Tevin Campbell, Jeremih.
他的视频背景音乐都是他喜欢的歌，有些已经是三十年前的作品了——路德·范德鲁斯、亚瑟小子、Jagged Edge、特文·坎贝尔、杰里迈等艺术家的R&B歌曲。
[MUSIC - RAHEEM DEVAUGHN, "CUSTOMER"]
[音乐 - 拉希姆·德沃恩，《客户》]
I recognize the music because I love this music, too. It hits me, watching, we're not that far apart in age.
我认得这些音乐，因为我也热爱这些歌曲。看着这些视频，我深受触动，我们在年龄上相差并不远。
The most TikTok thing Andre does in the 37 videos he posted? He lip-syncs to hip hop and R&B classics. In one, he mouths along to Raheem DeVaughn's 2008 song, "Customer."
安德烈发布的37个视频中最具TikTok风格的内容是什么？他为嘻哈和R&B经典老歌对口型。在其中一个视频里，他对着拉希姆·德沃恩2008年的歌曲《客户》做口型。
(SINGING) If your heart is hungry, you can place your order here with me. Let me serve you up, let me, let me serve you up--
(演唱) 如果你的心是饥饿的，你可以在我这里下单。让我为你服务，让我，让我为你服务——
Andre looks right into the camera in these videos, the frame super tight around his face and chest. And he emotes. He puts his hand to his chest and his temple, and points to the camera, landing the lyrics with intent. His beard is flecked with gray, so it's more salt and pepper than black.
安德烈在这些视频里直视镜头，画面紧紧框住他的脸和胸部。他投入情感。他把手放在胸口和太阳穴上，指着镜头，带着诚意吟唱歌词。他的胡须里夹杂着灰色，所以与其说是黑色，不如说是黑白相间。
[MUSIC - H-TOWN, "PART TIME LOVER"]
[音乐 - H-Town，《兼职情人》]
When he lip syncs to H-Town's "Part Time Lover," he really nails the ad-libs.
当他为H-Town的《兼职情人》做口型时，他真的抓住了即兴表演的精髓。
(SINGING) There is not another man who wouldn't take care of you. Right now, I know you're busy, baby, but let me be your part time fool.
(演唱) 没有别的男人能像我这样照顾你。现在，我知道你很忙，宝贝，但让我做你的兼职傻瓜。
Both those videos and a couple of others have the same caption-- for my wife. Love songs so easily fall into the realm of cheesy, singing along to them even more so. But Andre commits. He's feeling feelings. And on TikTok, if nowhere else, you can be earnest. These videos feel like something he hoped his partner would actually see and love.
这两个视频以及其他几个视频有着相同的标题——致我的妻子。情歌太容易落入俗套，跟着唱起来更是如此。但安德烈全身心投入。他感受到了那种情感。而在TikTok上，如果说还有什么地方能让你保持真诚，那就是这里。这些视频感觉像是他希望他的伴侣真正看到并爱上的内容。
For me, some of the most moving videos from Andre were a couple posted on the day DMX died, in April 2021. In both, he's wearing a maroon terry robe over his T-shirt, with his beard trimmed close. The idea of him posting those to honor the late rapper, a stranger who had moved him with his art, wrecks me. One of the lyrics Andre lip-syncs to is from 1998's "Slippin'"-- "If I'm strong enough, I'll live long enough to see my kids doing something more constructive with they time than bids."
对我来说，安德烈最感人的视频是2021年4月DMX去世那天发布的那两个。视频里他穿着一件紫红色毛圈浴袍，内搭T恤，胡须修剪得很整齐。想到他发布这些视频是为了纪念这位已故说唱歌手——一位用艺术打动了他的陌生人——让我感到极度心碎。安德烈对口型唱的一句歌词来自1998年的《Slippin'》——“如果我足够坚强，我能活得足够久，看到我的孩子们用比打架更有建设性的方式度过时光。”
The one thing that was repeated in news stories about Andre is that he'd gone to Tops that day to do something for his three-year-old son. He was there to pick up a birthday cake. He didn't live long enough.
新闻中关于安德烈反复提到的一点是，他那天去Tops是为了他三岁的儿子。他是去取生日蛋糕的。他没能活得更久。
[MUSIC - DMX, "SLIPPIN'"]
[音乐 - DMX，《Slippin'》]
Bim Adewunmi is one of the producers of our show.
比姆·阿德温米是我们节目的制作人之一。
Katherine Massey, age 72. After the Buffalo shooting, the fact that was repeated about Kat Massey was that she had written a letter to the newspaper calling for gun control about a year before she was murdered. When we started putting together today's program, talking to people who knew Kat Massey, and reading some of the many, many letters to the editor that she wrote, and all the different things that she cared about, we immediately thought of the writer Eve Ewing. Here she is.
凯瑟琳·梅西，72岁。布法罗枪击案后，关于凯特·梅西反复被提及的事实是，她在被害前一年左右曾致信报社呼吁枪支管制。当我们开始筹备今天的节目时，采访了认识凯特·梅西的人，并阅读了她写的许多许多致编辑的信，以及她关心的所有不同事情，我们立即想到了作家伊芙·尤因。她在这儿。
Probably like a lot of people, and maybe in particular like a lot of Black people, I've been turning away from the news from Buffalo. It felt too hurtful to sit with. But then, when the show reached out and told me about Kat, things changed.
可能像很多人一样，也许特别是像很多黑人一样，我一直试图避开关于布法罗的新闻。坐下来面对这些太痛苦了。但后来，当节目组联系我并告诉我关于凯特的事时，情况变了。
I never met Katherine "Kat" Massey. But when I read about her life, I felt a kinship with her. Because by all accounts, Kat was a certified member of a group to which I also proudly belong-- the busybody club. Aunties, literal or figurative, doers of the most, that one person you know that's all up on everything, not for the sake of being nosy or in people's business, but someone who, when they see something that could be safer, smarter, better, more accessible, cleaner, more equitable, does something about it.
我从未见过凯瑟琳·“凯特”·梅西。但当我读到她的生平时，我感到一种亲近感。因为据所有记录显示，凯特是一位认证会员，而我也自豪地属于这个群体——“爱管闲事俱乐部”。阿姨们，无论是在现实中还是比喻中，都是最积极的行动派，就是你知道的那种对每件事都了如指掌的人，不是为了打听隐私或插手别人的事，而是当她们看到什么事情本可以更安全、更明智、更好、更易用、更干净、更公平的时候，就会付诸行动。
I'm gonna give you an example. Here's a story people love to tell about Kat, maybe because it's a story she loved to tell about herself. But I got to hear it from her friend and frequent co-conspirator, Ms. Betty Jean Grant.
我给你举个例子。人们喜欢讲这样一个关于凯特的故事，也许是因为她自己也喜欢讲。但我还是从她的朋友兼频繁的合作者贝蒂·简·格兰特女士那里听到了这个故事。
Kat was trying to get something done, some improvements on her street. And she wrote a letter to the governor. He was unmoved. He hit her back and was like, isn't that something a block club would normally handle?
凯特当时正试图完成一件事，对她所在的街道进行一些改进。她写信给州长。州长没被打动。他回信说，这不是应该由街区俱乐部来处理的事情吗？
But he said, if you get your block club to write a letter, then we'll consider that letter. He assumed she had a block club when she did not. And so she, [LAUGHS] being the resourceful, resourceful person that she is and was, she gets letterhead that she created from the Cherry Street Block Club, and she wrote that request to the governor.
但他又说，如果你的街区俱乐部写信，那我们就考虑。他假定她有一个街区俱乐部，实际上她并没有。于是，[笑]身为资源丰富、充满智慧的人，她创作了“樱桃街街区俱乐部”的信头，并以那个名义给州长写了请求信。
On the low, the Cherry Street Block Club was, shall we say, aspirational. It had exactly one member-- president, founder, treasurer, secretary, letterhead designer all rolled into one lady-- Katherine Massey. And that turned out to be enough to get the job done.
悄悄说一句，这个“樱桃街街区俱乐部”可以说是“志向远大”。它只有一名成员——主席、创始人、财务主管、秘书、信头设计师集于一身——凯瑟琳·梅西。而这居然足够把事情办成了。
Once it was approved, Kat said, oh, my god, you know? I got to form this block club.
一旦申请被批准，凯特说，噢，天哪，你知道吗？我必须真的成立这个俱乐部。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I got this done with a block club that doesn't exist. So I got to form a block club.
我用一个不存在的俱乐部把事情办成了。所以我得真的成立一个。
And so she did. That's how the Cherry Street Block Club was born. Now, busybody 101 is the person who's out in the park picking up trash or making sure kids have something to eat.
于是她真的成立了。樱桃街街区俱乐部就这样诞生了。现在，爱管闲事入门级的人是在公园里捡垃圾或确保孩子们有东西吃的人。
But the advanced busybody is the one who knows how to rally the people. They understand how to build a collective vision. And they've got the charisma and persuasive talents to do it. That was Kat-- elite level busybody.
但高级版的“爱管闲事”是那些知道如何团结众人的人。她们懂得如何构建集体愿景。她们有魅力和说服力去实现它。这就是凯特——精英级的爱管闲事者。
Let me tell you another story, this time from somebody who wasn't Kat's close friend.
让我再给你讲个故事，这次是关于一个并不是凯特密友的人。
Well, my name is Michael Christner, actually Mike. Worked for 25 years at the New York State Department of Transportation.
嗯，我叫迈克尔·克里斯纳，其实叫迈克。在纽约州交通部工作了25年。
Mike Christner met Kat the way various other political officials slash school principals slash city council people met Kat. Someone came into his office and said, there's a lady downstairs waiting to meet with you. Mike had been assigned to a project near Kat's house.
迈克·克里斯纳遇见凯特的方式，和各种官员、校长或市议员遇见她的方式一样。有人走进他的办公室说，楼下有位女士等着见你。迈克当时被分配负责凯特家附近的一个项目。
What was the official title of the project?
那个项目的正式名称是什么？
I don't remember what the official title was. Usually, our titles are very long and very boring.
我不记得正式名称了。通常我们的标题都很长而且很无聊。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
So it was something like replacement of the railing on top of the retaining wall along state highway blank, blank, blank. So it would make no sense. And she found out-- I'm not sure how, but she found out that we had this project.
所以大概是像“沿着州立高速公路空白、空白、空白的挡土墙上方更换栏杆”之类的。所以这根本没意义。我不确定她是怎么发现的，但她发现了我们有这个项目。
And she came in. And sat down and talked to us, and actually asked us or told us, what are you going to do for me, and for us, and for my neighborhood?
于是她进来了。坐下和我们谈话，实际上是问我们或告诉我们，你们打算为我，为我们，还有为我的社区做什么？
Kat's house faced the highway-- like, sit on your front porch looking at a highway-type faced the highway. And she was tired of it. Her neighborhood, like a lot of Black neighborhoods in the United States, has an expressway cutting through it. The part that ran by Kat's house was built out in the 1960s, a period when the federal government was incentivizing highway expansion in a way that often involved bisecting or flat out bulldozing communities of color, sometimes incidentally, sometimes on purpose.
凯特的房子正对着高速公路——那种坐在前廊看着高速公路的房子。她厌倦了。她的社区，像美国许多黑人社区一样，有一条高速公路从中穿过。凯特房子旁边的部分建于20世纪60年代，当时联邦政府正在鼓励高速公路扩张，这往往涉及到将有色人种社区一分为二或直接推平，有时是意外，有时是故意的。
Between Kat's house and all the cars, there was a rusting railing that was falling apart. So somehow or other, Kat figured out the guy who she could talk to about it. And she used her tried and true method-- she showed up in his office. And she brought a friend with her. Remember, collective vision.
在凯特的房子和所有汽车之间，有一道生锈的栏杆正在坍塌。所以不知怎么的，凯特找到了她能谈话的那个人。她用了她那屡试不爽的方法——她出现在他的办公室里。她还带了一个朋友。记住，集体愿景。
As Mike recalls it, they sat down, reached into a bag, and pulled out a piece of kente cloth. They put it down in front of him.
迈克回忆说，她们坐下来，伸手进包里，拿出一块肯特布。她们把它放在了他面前。
Now, that must have been surprising.
那一定很令人惊讶。
Yes, it was.
是的，确实如此。
And what did they say?
她们说了什么？
Kat looked at me. And Kat asked, what are you going to do with this? How can you incorporate this into your project?
凯特看着我。凯特问，你打算怎么处理这个？你怎么把它融入到你的项目中？
I mean, I assume that up to that moment, you had no plans to incorporate any type of kente cloth.
我的意思是，我假设在那一刻之前，你根本没打算融入任何类型的肯特布。
I've never done anything like that before, but I was elated, actually. And I looked at this as an opportunity.
我以前从没做过这样的事，但我当时真的很兴奋。我把它看作是一个机会。
The fact that Mike saw this moment as an opportunity, that was something Kat brought out in people. Kat's sister, Barbara, says that one of Kat's many catchphrases was, "this is a question-suggestion." I love this phrase. It's brilliant, it's inviting, and it's assertive. It says, I have a vision, but figure it out with me.
迈克将这一刻视为一个机会，这就是凯特激发人的地方。凯特的妹妹芭芭拉说，凯特的口头禅之一是，“这是一个提问式的建议”。我喜欢这个表达。它很棒，既吸引人又坚定。它传达的是：我有一个愿景，但请和我一起把它实现吧。
What Kat couldn't have known before she met Mike was that by recruiting him to be on Team Busybody, she was also helping him see his vision through. Mike, and I mean this in the most flattering way possible, is a transportation nerd. This dude is passionate.
凯特在遇见迈克之前不可能知道，通过招募他加入“爱管闲事团队”，她也在帮助他实现他的愿景。迈克，我指的是最令人赞赏的一面，是个交通书呆子。这家伙充满激情。
A couple of months before this time, I was in Minneapolis-Saint Paul. And I looked at the railings and the public streets that they have, and I noticed that they had a lot of interesting railing art-- art on the railings, and art on the walls.
就在那段时间的前几个月，我在明尼阿波利斯-圣保罗。我注意到他们公共街道上的栏杆，我发现他们有很多有趣的栏杆艺术——栏杆上的艺术，墙上的艺术。
Do you often, when you travel or you go to different places, do you look at railings a lot?
当你旅行或去不同的地方时，你经常会看栏杆吗？
Oh, I look at everything. Even as a kid, I used to stare out the window as, like, driving down the highway. And then she walked in and showed me this kente cloth. And I-- one and one equaled two. It seemed like a perfect match.
噢，我观察一切。即使还是个孩子的时候，我就喜欢在开车经过高速公路时盯着窗外看。然后她走进来展示了这块肯特布。我就——1加1等于2。这看起来简直是完美搭配。
Mike told Kat that the exact kente cloth pattern would be hard to replicate-- too many fine lines to be rendered in concrete. But they brainstormed and came up with something else-- Adinkra symbols from Ghana representing different principles and ideas, like a Sankofa bird with the words, "go back and retrieve." They thought the symbols and words would be cool to look at, but also achieve Kat's goal of inspiring people in the neighborhood to learn a bit about West African heritage and the Black diaspora. They worked together, and the plan was approved-- amazing. The end.
迈克告诉凯特，要精确复制肯特布的图案很难——混凝土上渲染不了那么细的线条。但他们一起集思广益，想到了别的——来自加纳的阿丁克拉符号，代表不同的原则和想法，比如“Sankofa”鸟，配上文字“回归并找回”。他们认为这些符号和文字看起来很酷，也能实现凯特的初衷，即激励社区居民多了解一些西非文化和黑人侨民史。他们合作完成了，方案被批准了——太棒了。结束。
Psych. This is the government. Of course it took forever. And Kat wasn't going to let up. Getting her plan in place wasn't enough.
骗你的。这是政府。当然花了好长好长时间。而凯特是不会松懈的。她的计划被批准还不够。
Well, Kat would call us occasionally, about every-- every three or six months, ask us to give her an update. How are things going? How are things coming along? When can we expect something? Not quite realizing the process that we go through and how long it takes.
嗯，凯特偶尔会打电话给我们，每隔——每隔三到六个月，问我们索要进度更新。情况怎么样了？进展如何？什么时候能看到东西？她并没有完全意识到我们经历的流程以及它需要多长时间。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
However, she was still very supportive. I mean, she'd always walk into the room with a big smile on her face. And she was-- while she wanted things, she wasn't demanding or pushy. She had a personality that you really wanted to help.
然而，她仍然非常支持。我的意思是，她总是带着灿烂的笑容走进房间。虽然她想要事情有所进展，但她从不苛求或咄咄逼人。她的性格让你真的很想帮她。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
You wanted to help her.
你真的想帮她。
And you said 25 years was your amount of time at the Department, is that correct? 25--
你说在部门工作了25年，对吗？25——
That's correct, yep, 25 years.
没错，是的，25年。
In that 25 years, how many times would you say you had a resident calling frequently to check up on you with the progress of a project?
在这25年里，你会说有多少次有居民频繁打电话来核对项目进度？
She is the only one.
她是唯一一个。
She would always send us a Christmas card--
她总是会给我们寄圣诞贺卡——
Wow.
哇。
--every year, even after the project was completed. And she'd address it to me and the A-Team-- that's what she called us.
——每年都会，即使项目完成之后。而且她会寄给我和“A团队”——那是她对我们的称呼。
[LAUGHS] Did anybody else send you Christmas cards to your office?
[笑]还有其他人寄过圣诞贺卡到你们办公室吗？
Nobody.
没有别人。
Nobody. Wow, not even the streets and sanitation people? Or are you guys, like, rivals with them?
没人。哇，连环卫部门的人也没有？还是你们和他们是竞争对手？
Well, I wouldn't call it rivals. But we-- we do a mutual job.
嗯，我不会称之为竞争对手。但我们——我们共同协作。
In 2012, Kat wrote her own obituary. I'm going to read you some excerpts, a little bit of what she wanted us to know about her. Here it is.
2012年，凯特写下了自己的讣告。我要为你读一些摘要，关于她希望我们了解她的一些内容。就是这里。
Kat did not hesitate from being a committee of one. Once, she picketed her landlord's restaurant for the lack of heat in her apartment. One of her proudest moments in a time when she nearly got cold feet was her appearance as Ms. Broc-cooli-- her invention. That's broccoli with the word cool in it. It's a pun-- at a health assembly at the Dr. Lydia T. Wright School.
凯特从不介意担任“一人委员会”。有一次，她因为公寓没暖气而在房东的餐馆前抗议。在她职业生涯中最自豪的时刻之一，是在一次学校健康集会上扮演“西兰花小姐”——这是她的发明。那是把西兰花（broccoli）和“酷”（cool）结合起来。这是一个双关语——在莉迪亚·T·赖特博士学校的健康集会上。
Her rented broccoli costume was accessorized by sunglasses and leopard gloves. She performed the rap song written by her for the occasion. She often said she was a single parent with 35,000 adopted children attending Buffalo's public schools.
她租来的西兰花服装搭配了太阳镜和豹纹手套。她表演了自己为那个场合写的说唱歌曲。她常说她是一个单亲母亲，有35000个在布法罗公立学校上学的“领养孩子”。
Kat was an upbeat people person with a well-used smile. She was not an inside the box individual, as her home's unusual decorations, such as a knight in armor, demonstrated. And oh, yes, she didn't mind expressing her opinion-- in newspaper editorials, at school board and community meetings, at Blue Cross Blue Shield, where she worked, in the barber shop, at bus stops, in train stations, via online blogs, or wherever.
凯特是一个乐观的人，笑容满面。她不是一个墨守成规的人，正如她家不同寻常的装饰（比如一个穿着盔甲的骑士）所展示的那样。哦，是的，她不介意表达自己的观点——在报纸社论、学校董事会和社区会议上，在蓝十字蓝盾保险公司（她工作的地方），在理发店，在公交车站，在火车站，通过在线博客，或者任何地方。
Kat wrote another thing about her own passing-- a letter to her family encouraging them to prepare for the idea of her being gone. She said, I don't know why Patti had to leave first. But my prayer is for me to be the next to go. I'm overdue. I told Patti, don't let me be a wimp when it's my time. And don't none of you be wimps, either. That last part is underlined.
凯特还写了关于她自己离世的另一件事——一封给家人的信，鼓励他们为她不在的局面做好准备。她说，我不明白为什么帕蒂必须先走。但我的祈祷是让我成为下一个。我早该走了。我告诉帕蒂，我走的时候不要表现得软弱。你们任何人都不要软弱。最后那部分是有下划线的。
I told you earlier that when I saw news about Buffalo, I would look away. Looking away can be a thing you have to do sometimes to protect yourself. But looking away forever also makes it impossible to really grieve. Grief requires you to hold on to something, to sit with it, to look at it, consider it, cry, be mad.
我之前告诉你，当我看到关于布法罗的新闻时，我会选择避开。有时候为了保护自己，你必须选择避开。但永远避开也让人无法真正哀悼。哀悼要求你坚持住某样东西，与它同在，审视它，思考它，哭泣，愤怒。
And I get the sense that Kat would have really, really wanted us to do all those things. Because she didn't look away. Kat showed up.
我感觉到凯特会真心实意地希望我们做所有这些事情。因为她没有选择避开。凯特挺身而出。
We need people like Kat-- the people who aren't paid to care, who aren't experts who know everything. They're just the folks who are willing to make the sign, meet the principal, call the governor, put on the rapping broccoli costume. The few, the proud, the busybodies.
我们需要像凯特这样的人——那些没有报酬却依然关心的人，那些不是什么都知道的专家的人。他们只是愿意去制作抗议牌、会见校长、打电话给州长、穿上西兰花说唱服的人。少数的、自豪的、爱管闲事的人。
Eve Ewing in Chicago. Her website is eveewing.com.
伊芙·尤因在芝加哥。她的网站是eveewing.com。
Coming up, a man and a deacon get into a car. Money is exchanged. The man is confused. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个男人和一个执事上了一辆车。金钱被交换了。男人很困惑。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today is about the 10 people killed at Tops grocery in Buffalo this May. I think the world moved on from that event a little too quickly.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目是关于今年5月在布法罗Tops超市遇害的10个人。我认为世界从那场事件中走出来的速度太快了。
And today, we're talking about things about them that get left out when we speed past these moments of mass violence. Small things, like Margus Morrison, 52, a school bus aide, father of six. Several people remember him as bubbly, funny, though his cousin and his brother, Frederick, said OK, sometimes he really wasn't as funny as he thought.
今天，我们谈论的是在这些大规模暴力时刻被我们忽略的关于他们的点点滴滴。小事，比如52岁的马格斯·莫里森，一名校车助手，六个孩子的父亲。几个人记得他活泼、有趣，尽管他的表弟和兄弟弗雷德里克说，好吧，有时候他真的没他自己想的那么有趣。
Well, you know how you tell a joke, but it's only humor to you? But just to make you feel good, we'll laugh with you anyway?
嗯，你知道那种讲笑话的方式吗，但只有你自己觉得好笑？但为了让你感觉良好，我们会不管怎样都跟着笑？
Totally.
完全同意。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Do you remember any of his jokes?
你记得他的任何笑话吗？
I don't. They were corny, but just laugh with him anyway. [LAUGHS]
不记得了。它们很老套，但反正会跟着他笑。[笑]
Fredrick did remember some of his brother's dirty jokes, but didn't want to share those on the radio. The brothers, they were two years apart. And they saw each other all the time.
弗雷德里克确实记得他兄弟的一些黄段子，但不想在广播里分享。这对兄弟，他们只差两岁。他们经常见面。
Every day.
每天。
For real? Every day?
真的吗？每天？
Every day, every chance we get. You see him, you see me. That's why people used to think we were twins, 'cause we always together.
每天，只要有机会。你看到他，就看到我。这就是为什么人们过去常以为我们是双胞胎，因为我们总是待在一起。
Yeah.
是的。
And we look alike. And we look alike.
而且我们长得像。我们长得像。
Margus would text him or call him, saying, open the back door. And they'd sit and chat in Frederick's living room, Margus on the brown recliner, Frederick on the couch. They'd watch TV. They liked stand-up. They listened to music together.
马格斯会给他发短信或打电话，说，把后门打开。然后他们会坐在弗雷德里克的客厅里聊天，马格斯坐在棕色的躺椅上，弗雷德里克坐在沙发上。他们看电视。他们喜欢脱口秀。他们一起听音乐。
That's what Frederick says he misses the most-- something that doesn't have a particular name. Not a dramatic memory with his brother, just hanging out, the daily-ness of it.
这就是弗雷德里克说他最怀念的事情——某种没有特定名字的东西。不是和他兄弟一起的什么戏剧性的记忆，只是待在一起，那种日常。
Next up-- Geraldine Chapman Talley, age 62. People in Buffalo told us that pretty much everybody who's there who's Black knows somebody who died May 14. And the effects of violence like this, a gunman showing up to specifically kill Black people, ripple out from the families involved to those like that who knew them, to people all over the country, especially Black people who are thinking it through.
接下来——杰拉尔丁·查普曼·塔利，62岁。布法罗的人们告诉我们，基本上所有那里的黑人都认识5月14日死于那场暴力的人。这种暴力带来的影响——枪手专门出现去杀害黑人——从涉及的家庭扩散到那些认识他们的人，再到全国各地的人，特别是那些正在思考这件事的黑人。
For his story, Kiese Laymon wanted to talk through one fact in particular about Geraldine Chapman Talley's life with someone he knows.
对于他的故事，基斯·莱蒙想和一位他认识的人探讨杰拉尔丁·查普曼·塔利生平中的一个事实。
Geraldine Chapman Talley, Gerri by her friends and family. She was the seventh of nine children and graduated from East High School in 1977. She was an excellent cook and baker. She had a daughter, a son, and a stepdaughter. Not long after learning she was about to become a grandmother for the first time, Chapman Talley was murdered in a Tops supermarket in Buffalo, New York.
杰拉尔丁·查普曼·塔利，朋友和家人叫她格里。她是九个孩子中的第七个，1977年毕业于东高中。她是一位出色的厨师和烘焙师。她有一个女儿，一个儿子和一个继女。在得知自己即将第一次成为祖母后不久，查普曼·塔利就在纽约州布法罗的一家Tops超市被害了。
Here's the part that felt most familiar and ultimately most terrifying about this American story. Gerri Chapman Talley was born in Grove Hill, Alabama, and moved to Buffalo when she was 11. That move, Grove Hill, Alabama, to Buffalo, New York, I heard that. And I had the same reaction as my friend, Zandria Robinson, who, like me, left the deep south for the north.
这是美国故事中感觉最熟悉、最终也最令人恐惧的部分。格里·查普曼·塔利出生于阿拉巴马州的格罗夫希尔，11岁时搬到了布法罗。那个搬迁，从阿拉巴马州的格罗夫希尔到纽约州的布法罗，我听到了。我的反应和我朋友赞德里亚·罗宾逊一样，她像我一样离开了南部深处去往北方。
Zandria was raised right up the road. I'm from Jackson, Mississippi, and she's from Memphis, Tennessee.
赞德里亚是在路边长大的。我来自密西西比州的杰克逊，她来自田纳西州的孟菲斯。
I mean, my immediate thought was just, we went all the way up there just to die the same way that we were trying not to die.
我的第一个念头就是，我们历尽千辛万苦搬到那里，结果却死在了我们试图逃离的那种方式里。
Wow.
哇。
I wanted to talk to Zandria because she wrote the book Chocolate Cities with Dr. Marcus Hunter. They drew the map on Black migratory paths in America. Zandria is a professor of African-American Studies at Georgetown, so that's Dr. Robinson to y'all.
我想采访赞德里亚，因为她和马库斯·亨特博士合著了《巧克力城市》这本书。他们绘制了美国黑人迁徙路径图。赞德里亚是乔治城大学非裔美国人研究专业的教授，所以你们得叫她罗宾逊博士。
On the Black map they drew, Buffalo isn't the North or even the Northeast. It's part of something called the up south. And Alabama, like Mississippi, like Memphis, is a part of something called the deep south. Zandria told me Ms. Chapman Talley's people made the move later than most, in 1971.
在他们绘制的黑人地图上，布法罗既不是北方，甚至也不是东北部。它是所谓“上南方”的一部分。而阿拉巴马，就像密西西比，就像孟菲斯，是所谓“深南部”的一部分。赞德里亚告诉我，查普曼·塔利女士一家比大多数人搬得晚，是在1971年。
So Buffalo, there was a bunch of Black people there already.
所以布法罗，那里已经有很多黑人了。
Yeah.
是的。
They had cultivated a Black side of town.
他们已经开辟了城市里的黑人区。
Right.
对。
They found up there, definitely an up south, or definitely a north that was the south.
他们在那里找到的，绝对是一个“上南方”，或者说一个属于南方的北方。
Definitely an up south.
绝对是上南方。
Definitely an up south. But it was still something different.
绝对是上南方。但它仍然有些不同。
I told Zandria that when I talked to Chapman Talley's family, I heard the story of how the Chapmans arrived in Buffalo a few different ways. Chapman Talley's niece, Tamika Harper, says the family was coming up to Niagara Falls from Alabama for a family vacation.
我告诉赞德里亚，当我采访查普曼·塔利的家人时，我听到了几个不同版本的关于查普曼一家抵达布法罗的故事。查普曼·塔利的侄女塔米卡·哈珀说，这家人当时正从阿拉巴马去尼亚加拉瀑布家庭度假。
Something happened to the car, she says. Chapman Talley's father found a job paying better than Alabama, and ended up staying. Hattie Chapman Steele, Chapman Talley's older sister by six years, recalls a slightly different story. She says that the family moved to Buffalo because their mother found out she had a sister in Buffalo. Zandria said it's hard to really grasp the enormity or the psychic toll of these migrations, whether one was moving up and over a few counties or all the way across the country.
她说车坏了。查普曼·塔利的父亲找到了一份比阿拉巴马薪水更高的工作，最终留了下来。比查普曼·塔利大六岁的姐姐哈蒂·查普曼·斯蒂尔回忆的故事略有不同。她说这家人搬到布法罗是因为他们的母亲发现她在布法罗有个姐妹。赞德里亚说，这些迁徙带来的巨大影响或心理代价很难真正理解，无论是一个人往上搬迁几个县，还是横跨整个国家。
You know, in my father's case, I'm leaving Glendora, Mississippi, and I'm going to Memphis.
你知道，在我父亲的案例里，我离开密西西比州的格伦多拉，去往孟菲斯。
Yes.
是的。
That is, for somebody who lived the county, two counties over from where Emmett Till was murdered, that's a big move.
对于一个生活在埃米特·蒂尔遇害地外两个县的人来说，那是一个重大的搬迁。
It's huge.
它是巨大的。
It's a huge move. So to imagine the Chapmans saying, all right, we're going from the bottom to the top, that's symbolic. It's geographical. It's cognitive. And it meant that Ms. Gerri ended up with a different kind of life than she would have had in Alabama.
这是一个巨大的搬迁。所以想象一下查普曼一家说，好吧，我们从最底层搬到最顶层，这具有象征意义。这是地理上的。这是认知上的。这意味着格里女士最终过上了一种与在阿拉巴马完全不同的生活。
Gerri's older sister, Hattie, said that for her, the move to Buffalo was difficult. Hattie was 18 years old. And though she was eager to see what Buffalo had to offer, she was still deeply connected to Alabama. But Gerri was much younger, and she took to Buffalo quickly.
格里的姐姐哈蒂说，对她来说，搬到布法罗很困难。哈蒂当时18岁。虽然她渴望看到布法罗能提供什么，但她仍然与阿拉巴马紧密相连。但格里当时还小得多，她很快就适应了布法罗。
Zandria and I talked a while about what young Gerri's life might have been like in Buffalo. In our deep south, it was ritual to sit on a porch cradled by humidity, or in an idling Impala, considering the journey of Black folk who left home and never made it back.
我和赞德里亚聊了很久关于年轻的格里在布法罗的生活可能是什么样的。在我们的深南部，坐在被潮湿空气包围的门廊上，或者在怠速的黑斑羚车里，思考着那些离开家园再也没有回来的黑人们的旅程，是一种仪式。
And, like, this is the thing I love about talking to you because there's something either deeply Black American, deeply Southern Black American about what we're doing now, which is a kind of attempt at eulogy, elegy, really loving someone that we did not particularly individually know know, but we felt like we might have known part of their journey.
这就是我喜欢和你聊天的地方，因为我们现在正在做的事情里，有一种深深的黑人美国属性，深深的南方黑人美国属性，这是一种悼词、挽歌的尝试，真正爱着一个我们并不特别认识的人，但我们觉得我们可能认识他们旅程的一部分。
We say these things, we know these people. And I'm just hurt a lot that we don't get to know more about her, from her.
我们说这些话，我们认识这些人。我真的很心痛，我们没能从她本人那里更多地了解她。
You write a lot about what we are owed in life as folks from-- Black folks from the deep south, and what kinds of-- I'm interested in-- you can talk to me about what kinds of death are we owed when we leave home, or are carried from home for a different kind of freedom? People always want to talk about this repair, and reparation, or whatnot. What kind of deaths are we owed, whether we stay home in the deep south, and particularly in this situation, whether we go to these corners of the nation that might be a little bit different or a lot different from our Southern homes?
你写了很多关于作为深南部的黑人，我们在生活中被亏欠的东西，以及什么样的——我对此很感兴趣——你可以跟我谈谈，当我们离开家园，或者为了寻求另一种自由而背井离乡时，我们被亏欠什么样的死亡？人们总是想谈论修补、赔偿之类的。我们被亏欠什么样的死亡，无论我们是留在深南部的老家，还是在这个特殊的情况下，我们去了国家的这些角落，可能与我们的南方家园有一点点不同或很多不同？
I think we're owed the death of our choosing.
我认为我们被亏欠了我们所选择的死亡。
(WHISPERS) Yes.
(低语) 是的。
And that might seem hyperbolic because, of course, God and all of that. But I would say that of all the things, I would hope that people would be able to be peaceful, quiet, surrounded by music, love, and family, chosen and otherwise, and whoever else they wanted to be there.
这看起来可能有点夸张，因为上帝之类的。但我会说，在所有事情中，我希望人们能够平静、安静，被音乐、爱和家庭（选择的和血缘的）所包围，以及任何他们想让在那儿的人。
(WHISPERS) Yes.
(低语) 是的。
Being able to move into the light in ways of their own choosing. That's what this country owes to all Black people as reparations, to be able to choose. But this manner-- yes, to be lynched-- that's all the way up in the corner, next to Canada.
能够以他们自己的选择方式步入光明。这就是这个国家欠所有黑人的赔偿，即能够做出选择。但这种方式——是的，被私刑处死——那是在角落里，靠近加拿大的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
And I know what America is.
我知道美国是什么样的。
Right.
对。
I wasn't like, oh my god, this happened up north.
我不会说，哦，天哪，这发生在北方。
Right, right--
对，对——
Obviously, I know what America is.
显然，我知道美国是什么样的。
Yes.
是的。
I've always known this. Yet to go so far, and then to not have a choice, to have that choice made for you in that way, that's not acceptable, to take people like this. And I think that being able to choose our exits, choose which way we going to go off the stage--
我一直都知道。然而走了那么远，却没能有选择，在这个意义上被剥夺了选择，这是不可接受的，夺走像这样的人。而且我认为，能够选择我们的离开，选择我们要以何种方式走下舞台——
Yes.
是的。
--is so essential.
——是如此重要。
Geraldine Chapman Talley did not get to choose how she left Buffalo. Tamika shared some of the regular texts she'd exchanged with her aunt. And two in particular got to me.
杰拉尔丁·查普曼·塔利没能选择她如何离开布法罗。塔米卡分享了一些她和她阿姨交流的日常短信。其中两条特别触动我。
In one of Chapman Talley's messages to her niece, she rejoices at her recent negative COVID tests, and thanks her niece for all the care and concern as she battles a prolonged back problem. "Happy to say I'm negative for COVID," Chapman Talley texted Harper. "Just to hear a concerned family member voice can feel they are for real. Means the world to me. You have always checked on me throughout my years of illness. There will always be a place in my" heart emoji "for you."
在查普曼·塔利发给侄女的一条信息中，她对自己最近的新冠检测阴性表示欣喜，并感谢侄女在她对抗长期的背部问题时给予的关心。“很高兴地说我新冠阴性了，”查普曼·塔利发短信给哈珀。“只是听到一个关心我的家人的声音，就能感到那是真实的。这对我来说意义重大。在我生病的这些年里，你一直关心着我。在我心中，永远有一个位置留给你。”
"Aw," Harper responded to the text from her aunt. "No thanks needed, my auntie slash mommy. I love you." Blowing kisses emoji.
“噢，”哈珀回复了她阿姨的短信。“不用谢，我的阿姨兼妈妈。我爱你。”附上了飞吻表情符号。
My auntie slash mommy.
我的阿姨兼妈妈。
A few weeks after 10 Black people are murdered in a grocery store in Western New York for being Black people in a grocery store in Western New York, nothing feels more deeply southern than the "my" preceding auntie slash mommy. That "my" desperately wants Geraldine Chapman Talley, a Black woman born in Grove Hill, Alabama, whose heartmeat seems as uniquely shaped as her migration journey to Buffalo-- to know she is cherished, connected, and most horrifying of all, safe.
在10名黑人在纽约西部一家杂货店因为是黑人而被谋杀后的几周里，没有比“我的”这个词出现在“阿姨兼妈妈”前面更具深南部色彩的了。这个“我的”迫切地想要杰拉尔丁·查普曼·塔利——一位出生在阿拉巴马州格罗夫希尔的黑人女性，她的心似乎和她前往布法罗的旅程一样独特——知道她是被珍惜的、被连接的，最恐怖的是，她是安全的。
Kiese Laymon, he's the author of the memoir Heavy and other books.
基斯·莱蒙，他是回忆录《沉重》和其他书的作者。
Ruth Whitfield, 86 years old. There's this line used over and over about the oldest victim, Ruth Whitfield, that she'd gone to Tops after visiting her husband that morning in a nursing home. BA Parker wanted to talk to her son, Garnell Jr., about what seemed to be a very long love story.
露丝·惠特菲尔德，86岁。关于最年长的受害者露丝·惠特菲尔德，有一句话被反复提及，那就是她在那天早上探望过住在疗养院的丈夫后去了Tops。BA·帕克想和她的儿子小加内尔谈谈那段看似非常漫长的爱情故事。
I sat down at Garnell Jr.'s dining room table hoping to hear stories about Ruth Whitfield and her husband, Garnell Sr., how they met, and who they were before having four children, and before the nursing home visits. But instead, I learned about how she loved secondhand shopping and singing the hymn, "Peace Be Still," how she got her GED late in life, and was adamant that no one call her Ruth, always Mrs. Whitfield, or how she once desperately rushed onto a football field when a teenage Garnell Jr. got injured during a game.
我坐在小加内尔的餐桌旁，希望听到关于露丝·惠特菲尔德和她丈夫老加内尔的爱情故事，他们是如何相遇的，在有了四个孩子之前，在疗养院探望之前，他们是谁。但我学到的是，她有多喜欢二手购物，喜欢唱赞美诗《和平静止》，她是怎样晚年才拿到GED证书，而且坚持没人叫她露丝，总是要叫惠特菲尔德夫人，或者她曾如何绝望地冲进橄榄球场，当十几岁的小加内尔在比赛中受伤时。
And I open my eyes, and I look up at my mom standing over me [LAUGHS] in the middle of the field and all of these people. My mom gonna run out on the field. [LAUGHS] And I said, mom, what are you doing out here? But--
我睁开眼睛，抬头看到妈妈站在我上面[笑]，在场地中间和所有人中间。我妈跑进场子里来了。[笑]我说，妈，你在这里做什么？但是——
Garnell Jr. is the second oldest, and a retired fire commissioner for the City of Buffalo. And he sat with me in his flip flops while his tiny dog rested at his feet. And instead of a love story about his parents, he told me a story about a car.
小加内尔是家里的老二，也是布法罗市的退休消防专员。他穿着人字拖坐在我身边，小狗趴在他的脚下。他没有讲他父母的爱情故事，而是讲了一个关于车的故事。
When Garnell Jr.'s dad first moved into the nursing home, Mrs. Whitfield wanted a car.
当小加内尔的父亲刚搬进疗养院时，惠特菲尔德夫人想买辆车。
So whatever, she got her first car in her name.
无论如何，她用自己的名字买了第一辆车。
Wait, were you at the dealership with her?
等等，你当时和她一起在经销商那里吗？
Oh, yeah, we were there. We were there. Oh, yeah. Because I think the first time-- because she had never done this before. And I didn't-- and she never had credit. She never had credit. It was my dad's credit. She never worked. She never had credit. No. So yeah, I was there.
哦，是的，我们在那里。我们在那里。哦，是的。因为我想第一次——因为她以前从来没做过这个。而且我没有——她从来没有信用记录。她从来没工作过。她从来没信用记录。没有。所以是的，我在那里。
So Mrs. Whitfield was in her early 80s, in a car dealership with three of her adult children, going back and forth about what car to get. She wanted something with a little flair, but her kids were pleading with her to be sensible. And so she ended up getting a Buick, which was fine.
惠特菲尔德夫人当时80出头，带着三个成年的孩子在车行里，为了买什么车来回争论。她想要一点风格，但孩子们恳求她要务实。于是她最终买了一辆别克，那还好。
What she bought-- she bought the SUV because she thought she would be-- it would be easier to get my father and take him on visits to the home or whatever from the nursing home. But as it turns out, she wasn't able to do that with him.
她买的——她买了SUV，因为她认为她会——那样会更容易带我父亲从疗养院去看病之类的。但事实证明，她没法那样带他。
At her age, it wasn't physically feasible for Mrs. Whitfield to help him into the car.
在她那个年龄，惠特菲尔德夫人要在体力上协助他上车是不可能的。
And so she regretted getting the SUV. She hated-- she ended up hating it. She hated it because that's not really what she wanted.
所以她后悔买了那辆SUV。她讨厌——最终她讨厌它。她讨厌它是因为那根本不是她想要的。
But that was kind of what Mrs. Whitfield always did-- take care of others, get the car she didn't really want because it could possibly help someone else. See, Mrs. Whitfield grew up on Grand Island, the small island right between Buffalo and Niagara Falls. And even as a kid, she was caring for siblings and cousins.
但这正是惠特菲尔德夫人一直做的事情——照顾别人，买她并不真正想要的车，因为它可能有助于帮助别人。你看，惠特菲尔德夫人在大岛长大，那是布法罗和尼亚加拉瀑布之间的一个小岛。即使作为孩子，她也一直照顾着兄弟姐妹和表亲。
And when she got married at 19, same thing. She was taking care of her husband and kids. Her house was the one that everyone in the neighborhood would come to.
当她在19岁结婚时，也是一样。她照顾着丈夫和孩子。她的家是社区里每个人都会来的地方。
So to Garnell Jr., hearing his mom described as a doting wife, sure. But it doesn't quite feel like enough.
所以对小加内尔来说，听到他的妈妈被描述为一个溺爱丈夫的妻子，当然。但这感觉还不够。
But they stayed together, you know? They stayed together. They loved each other. And everything was not hunky dory. Everything was not-- between them, they had problems over the years, you know?
但他们一直在一起，你知道吗？他们一直在一起。他们爱着对方。而且一切并非都风平浪静。一切并非——在他们之间，这些年来他们有过问题，你知道吗？
And it cost them. It cost her, you know? It cost her. She sacrificed a lot of her dreams, you know? She sacrificed them to stay together, and to stay with us.
这让他们付出了代价。这让她付出了代价，你知道吗？这让她付出了代价。她牺牲了她太多的梦想，你知道吗？她牺牲了它们以保持在一起，并和我们在一起。
When my father became debilitated, it's the first time in my mom's life that she was independent, had-- had that kind of independence, where she had to pay bills. She became the head of the household. And as difficult as it might have been, it was something that she relished, I think, you know? She got to be her own person and be in charge.
当我父亲变得虚弱时，这是我妈妈生命中第一次独立，有——有那种独立，她必须付账单。她成了户主。虽然这可能很难，但我觉得，她享受这一点，你知道吗？她成为了她自己，掌控着一切。
Garnell Jr. watched as his mom asserted herself and figured out what she wanted. When the staff at the nursing home would talk to Garnell Jr., his mom would get annoyed and say, you're talking to the wrong person. Talk to me.
小加内尔看着他的妈妈坚持自我，并弄清楚了她想要什么。当疗养院的工作人员和小加内尔谈话时，他妈妈会感到恼火并说，你们找错人了。跟我谈。
And she drove herself everywhere. Granted, she had three accidents this year. But Garnell insists that at least one of them wasn't her fault.
她开车去任何地方。当然，她今年发生了三次事故。但加内尔坚持认为至少其中一次不是她的错。
She started doing things she'd never done before, like taking herself on a vacation, solo, to Florida-- a first. And it was around this time that the new, independent Mrs. Ruth Whitfield, now 83, finally went shopping for the car that she actually wanted-- a 2020 Hyundai Elantra. And there was no fighting her on this one.
她开始做她以前从未做过的事情，比如独自度假去佛罗里达——这是第一次。就在这个时候，这位全新的、独立的露丝·惠特菲尔德夫人，现在83岁了，终于去选购了她真正想要的汽车——一辆2020款现代伊兰特。这一次没人能阻拦她。
When we went to get the car, the guy had a-- he had a 2019, brand-new, no miles on it, hadn't sold it. Great deal, great deal. She refused to take it because it wasn't new. It wasn't-- it had to be in the current year that we were there.
当我们去买车时，那个家伙有一辆——2019款的，全新的，没公里数，没卖出去。好交易，好交易。她拒绝接受，因为它不是新的。它不是——它必须是我们所在的那一年生产的。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Oh, we went around and around, and said, mama, are you kidding me? This is a great deal, ma. They're giving you this car, and it's a great deal, ma. No. She would have-- she got mad. Oh, it got to be a real thing between us.
噢，我们来来回回地争论，我说，妈妈，你在跟我开玩笑吗？这真的是个好交易，妈。他们给你这辆车，这是个好交易，妈。不。她生气了。噢，这在我们之间真的成了一件大事。
I said, ma, it doesn't-- no, I want it new. It's got to be in the current year. I don't care if nobody ever drove it before. It's got to be in this-- and that's how she was. So she got her-- she got her brand-new car, yeah.
我说，妈，没必要——不，我要新的。必须是当年款。我不在乎以前有没有人开过。必须是这一年的——她就是那样。所以她买了她那辆——她那辆全新的车，是的。
Again, this is a brand-new car, and she is 83 years old.
再说一次，这是一辆全新的车，而她83岁了。
Oh, she loved it. She got what she wanted. She had the sunroof, the heated seats, you know? She-- it had to be-- she wanted black. She got black. [INAUDIBLE] or something-- I want black. So she got her a black Hyundai Elantra.
噢，她爱死它了。她得到了她想要的。她有了天窗，加热座椅，你知道吗？她——它必须是——她想要黑色的。她买到了黑色。[听不清]或者其他什么——我想要黑色。所以她买了一辆黑色现代伊兰特。
And you had to know my mom. See, her car would be full of stuff all the time. She was a thrift-- she'd go to thrift stores, and she would just buy stuff. You know, she would just buy stuff. Some of it's very nice stuff. But she would have stuff in the car that's been sitting in there for, you know-- you know, they--
你必须了解我妈妈。你看，她的车里总是堆满了东西。她是旧货收藏者——她会去旧货店，然后她就会买东西。你知道，她就会买东西。有些东西非常不错。但她会在车里放些放了很久的东西，你知道——你知道，它们——
At Tops, when I saw a car similar to hers, that looked like hers, might be hers in the parking lot, I told the detectives and the police that were there cordoning off the area. I said, like, I see the roof of a black car sitting in that parking lot. I need you to go and look at that car, and see if it's my mother's car.
在Tops，当我看到一辆类似于她的车，看起来像她的，可能是她的车在停车场时，我告诉那里的探员和警察说。我说，我看到黑车的车顶停在那儿。我需要你们去看看那辆车，看看是不是我母亲的车。
As a former fire commissioner, he knew the police. And he ran down to Tops when he heard about the shooting to see if he could help. The car caught him by surprise.
作为一名前消防专员，他认识警察。他听到枪击案后跑到了Tops，看看自己是否能帮上忙。这辆车让他大吃一惊。
And they said, well, how would you know? What's the [INAUDIBLE]? I said, look in the car. It's going to be some kind of hat in the back window. It's going to probably be handwritten signs in the windows of their car. You know, it would be something-- something about God, something about the Buffalo Bills. [LAUGHS]
他们说，好吧，你怎么会知道？[听不清]是什么？我说，看车里。后窗里会有一种帽子。窗户上可能会有手写的标语。你知道，会有些——有些关于上帝的，关于布法罗比尔队的。[笑]
She was a note writer. Mirrors in the house, doorways in the house, they would have notes. So I knew that if they saw these things in the car, that would identify the car. And that's basically what happened, yeah.
她是个喜欢写字条的人。家里的镜子、门口，都会有字条。所以我知道，如果他们看到车里的这些东西，就能辨认出那辆车。基本上就是那样，是的。
Hmm.
嗯。
After Mrs. Whitfield died, Garnell Jr. kept some of the notes that his mother wrote-- some that were in the car, and more directly, the one she kept in her husband's room at the nursing home. One that stuck out read, God's got my back. She kept it in her husband's room to let everyone know not to be worried-- once again, taking care of everyone.
惠特菲尔德夫人去世后，小加内尔保留了一些他母亲写的字条——有些是在车里的，更多的是她留在疗养院丈夫房间里的。其中一张引人注目地写着：“上帝罩着我。”她把它留在丈夫的房间里，让大家知道不要担心——再一次，照顾着每一个人。
BA Parker is one of the hosts of Code Switch on NPR.
BA·帕克是NPR《代码转换》的主持人之一。
Roberta Drury, 32 years old. She was the first person killed, and the youngest person killed. Roberta moved to Buffalo from outside Syracuse to care for her brother, who was ill. She was described in a lot of stories as vibrant, funny, joyful. When we reached out to Damon Young to write about somebody for today's show, he asked specifically for Roberta.
罗伯塔·德鲁里，32岁。她是第一个被害的人，也是最年轻的受害者。罗伯塔从雪城郊外搬到布法罗来照顾她生病的哥哥。很多故事里都描述她充满活力、有趣、快乐。当我们联系戴蒙·杨为今天的节目写关于某人的故事时，他特别要求写罗伯塔。
If Roberta Drury and I happened to be acquaintances, if we were coworkers, if she were a neighbor, or if I were a new boyfriend of a cousin, the ask would have been subtle. If we happened to be close friends, though, I would have just came out with it. Roberta, your name-- what's the story there?
如果罗伯塔·德鲁里和我恰好是熟人，如果我们是同事，如果是邻居，或者如果我是她表姐的新男朋友，问起来会很委婉。但如果我们要好，我就会直接问了。罗伯塔，你的名字——有什么故事吗？
It was the second thing that struck me when first reading news stories about her. The first was her face, because she reminded me so much of a close friend of mine-- the smile, especially. It's eerie how a stranger can feel so familiar, so tactile from just a picture, how you can see and hear so much from a face, and how a face can sit inside of you and just stay there. But then there was her name.
这是第一次读关于她的新闻报道时，第二个让我印象深刻的点。第一个是她的脸，因为她让我想起了我很要好的一个朋友——尤其是笑容。陌生人通过一张照片就能让人感到如此熟悉、如此真切，这是多么诡异，你怎么能从一张脸上看到并听到这么多东西，以及一张脸怎么能留在你心里挥之不去。但随后就是她的名字。
It's funny sometimes how names work. Names like Tiffany and Amber, for instance, feel like the '80s and the '90s, like Pringles chips, Cross Colours jeans, and Nintendos. Names like Akil and Raheem feel East Coast, but not Atlanta, Miami, or Charlotte-- more like Philly, Baltimore, Brooklyn, and DC. Roberta, today, in 2022, it feels like a vestige of an earlier era, something almost ancestral.
有时名字的作用很有趣。例如，蒂芙尼和琥珀这样的名字感觉像是80年代和90年代，像品客薯片、Cross Colours牛仔裤和任天堂。阿基尔和拉希姆这样的名字感觉像是东海岸，但不是亚特兰大、迈阿密或夏洛特——更像是费城、巴尔的摩、布鲁克林和华盛顿。罗伯塔，今天，在2022年，感觉像是一个时代的遗迹，几乎是祖传的东西。
She was adopted at 18 months into a white family. The name came from her birth family. And it reminds me of power and laughter and love, of generous hugs and the baked candied yams you still taste three months after Thanksgiving. And I think it reminds me of those things because of the aunties, church ladies and grandmothers I've known and known of who were named that.
她在18个月大时被一个白人家庭收养。名字来自她的亲生家庭。它让我想起了力量、笑声和爱，想起了大方的拥抱和感恩节三个月后你依然能尝到的糖渍山药。我想它让我想起这些东西，是因为我认识或听说过的那些名字叫这个的阿姨们、教堂女士和祖母们。
The Roberta in my life is a great aunt. Everyone, at least everyone at New Castle, PA, calls her Birdie. My family also had a Peggy, a Betty, a Ruth, and a Gladys. It still has an Eleanor. And when the Peggies and Betties and Gladyses in our families leave us, those names usually leave us, too. But Roberta Drury, a 32-year-old in 2022, was here.
我生命中的罗伯塔是一位姨祖母。每个人，至少在新堡每个人，都叫她伯蒂。我家也有一位佩吉、贝蒂、露丝和格拉迪斯。现在还有一位埃莉诺。当家里那些佩吉、贝蒂和格拉迪斯离开我们时，这些名字通常也会随之而去。但罗伯塔·德鲁里，2022年的一位32岁的人，她存在过。
It's also funny how names can be predictive, which is an academic way of saying prophetic, and my way of saying that maybe Roberta was here because the world needed more Robertas-- more love, more vibrancy, more jubilance, more saying "I love you," and not just saying it, but leaning out the window and shouting it at your best friend, which is what Roberta's best friend, Krystle, said she always did.
名字能产生预示作用也很有趣，这是一种比较学术的说法，预言性，而我的说法是，也许罗伯塔存在过是因为世界需要更多的罗伯塔——更多的爱、更多的活力、更多的喜悦、更多地说“我爱你”，而且不仅仅是说说而已，而是从窗户探出身子，大声喊给你最好的朋友听，这就是罗伯塔最好的朋友克里斯特尔所说的她总是会做的事情。
More singing yourself to sleep, which is what Roberta's sister, Amanda, said she'd always do as a kid. She'd sing so forcefully, so joyfully, that it would drain her into slumber. Sometimes, her singing would be too loud, like when she'd call her half-sister, Nancy, at work, and Roberta would belt Whitney Houston's "I Wanna Dance with Somebody" so loudly that Nancy had to run outside to answer it. But Nancy would always pick up because, as Roberta would say, Whitney Houston is calling. You don't ignore Whitney.
更多地唱歌哄自己入睡，这是罗伯塔的妹妹阿曼达说的，她小时候总是这样。她唱歌那么用力，那么快乐，以至于她会累得睡着。有时，她的歌声太大了，比如她打电话给她的同父异母姐妹南希时，罗伯塔会用力唱惠特尼·休斯顿的《我想和你共舞》，声音大到南希不得不跑出去接。但南希总是会接，因为正如罗伯塔会说的，惠特尼·休斯顿打来了。你不能忽视惠特尼。
Talking to the people who knew her, I also learned that she didn't love her name. Her family knew her as Robbie. When she got older, she chose to be called Berta.
采访那些认识她的人，我还了解到她不喜欢自己的名字。她的家人叫她罗比。她长大后，选择了叫伯塔。
I get it. Roberta is a hard name for a young person to have. The Robertas in my life, I can't even picture them young. What I associate with that name is a product of years, decades of life. I just wish Roberta Drury had that chance, too.
我懂。罗伯塔对年轻人来说是个难听的名字。我生命中的罗伯塔们，我甚至无法想象她们年轻时的样子。我把这个名字与岁月的积淀联系在一起，是几十年的生活。我只是希望罗伯塔·德鲁里也有那个机会。
Damon Young is a contributing opinion writer at the Washington Post.
戴蒙·杨是《华盛顿邮报》的评论撰稿人。
Heyward Patterson, 67 years old. A quick heads up before we start this one-- this story talks a little about the day of the shooting and the violence that day. Heyward Patterson was deacon at State Tabernacle Church of God in Christ, grew up in Buffalo, loved to sing.
海沃德·帕特森，67岁。在开始这篇之前先提醒一下——这个故事稍微谈到了枪击案发生那天以及那天的暴力。海沃德·帕特森是神在基督教会州立帐幕的执事，在布法罗长大，喜欢唱歌。
Penny Beckham, who worked with Patterson at the church, says he had a beautiful voice. "I'm a Soldier in the Army of the Lord" was a favorite of his. He volunteered regularly at the soup kitchen Penny ran, Ms. Penny's Plate of Love food ministry.
佩妮·贝克汉姆在教堂和帕特森一起工作，说他有一副美丽的嗓音。《我是主军队里的士兵》是他最喜欢的歌。他经常在佩妮运营的流动厨房——“佩妮女士的爱之盘”食品部做志愿者。
Most volunteers, she said, don't spend a lot of time talking to the people who come in, some of whom are in a pretty bad way.
她说，大多数志愿者花在与前来求助的人交谈上的时间并不多，其中一些人处境相当糟糕。
But Deacon Patterson would go in, and he would talk to each individual. He wasn't judgmental. He let them know that their present state was not their expected end. And he would tell them about God's love, and how God's love transformed him from who he was to who he was that day.
但帕特森执事会走进去，他会与每个人交谈。他不加评判。他让人们知道他们目前的状态并不是他们的最终结局。他会向他们讲述上帝的爱，以及上帝的爱如何将他从过去变成了那天的他。
Michael Harriot, a writer for TheGrio, met somebody who watched Deacon Patterson a lot, mostly from a distance, somebody who saw him almost every day, including the day he died.
迈克尔·哈里奥特，《TheGrio》的一名作家，遇见了一个经常观察帕特森执事的人，多半是从远处，一个几乎每天都能看到他，包括在他去世当天看到他的人。
At the center of every Black neighborhood is the store. It's not a store, but the store, a nexus that serves as the de facto gathering spot. Tops was the store, and Grady Lewis was the quintessential man in front of the store.
每个黑人社区的中心都是杂货店。它不是一个普通的商店，而是“那个”杂货店，一个作为事实上的聚集地的核心。Tops就是那家店，格雷迪·刘易斯就是站在店前最具代表性的人。
Grady's work was what partly kept him around Tops. Almost every day, he pushed a shopping cart for miles, collecting bottles and cans. Then he'd bring them to Tops to collect the recycling return fee. Then he'd just hang for hours.
格雷迪的工作部分原因让他待在Tops周围。几乎每一天，他都会推着购物车走几英里，收集瓶子和罐子。然后他会把它们带到Tops领取回收返还费。然后他就待上几个小时。
The men in front of the store see everything. Grady knew when security guard Aaron Salter was scheduled to begin his shift. He could tell you when a new employee was hired. Everyone knew Grady.
店前的男人们看得到一切。格雷迪知道保安亚伦·萨尔特什么时候换班。他能告诉你什么时候雇佣了新员工。每个人都认识格雷迪。
My mother told me I never met a stranger. So I have no problems with chatting with anybody. I can walk up to anybody from anywhere and talk to them.
我妈妈告诉我我从来没遇见陌生人。所以我跟任何人聊天都没问题。我可以走到任何地方，和任何人交谈。
After he dropped his cans, Grady would hang out at the abandoned building across the street from the store. And that's where Grady first noticed the black Ford Fusion that would be in the Tops parking lot every day.
在扔掉他的罐子后，格雷迪会待在商店对面废弃的建筑物里。而就在那里，格雷迪第一次注意到了那辆每天都会出现在Tops停车场的黑色福特Fusion。
He'd put, like, a strip, a silver strip right there by the door. I would always be able to tell his car because of that strip it had on there.
他总是会在门边贴上一条银色的带子。只要有那条带子，我就总能认出他的车。
The car belonged to Heyward Patterson, the deacon. Grady knew Deacon from around East Buffalo, back when Deacon lived on the same block as Grady's uncle's, back when everyone used to call Deacon Patterson Teeny Boy. And he knew Deacon from Tops, where Deacon was a jitney driver, shuttling passengers back and forth to the neighborhood's only grocery store in his unofficial cab.
这辆车属于海沃德·帕特森，那位执事。格雷迪在东布法罗就认识这位执事，那时候执事住在格雷迪叔叔同一个街区，那时候每个人都叫帕特森执事为“小小伙”。而且他从Tops认识了这位执事，执事在那里是一名非法出租车司机，用他的私家车载着乘客往返于社区唯一的这家杂货店。
But Grady didn't know know Deacon until one day, Grady was sitting in his usual spot at the abandoned building across from Tops, and then Deacon called Grady over to the parking lot. He asked if Grady wouldn't mind helping one of his jitney customers carry her bags. Grady knew Deacon had a bad knee and couldn't climb stairs.
但格雷迪并不真正“了解”这位执事，直到有一天，格雷迪坐在Tops对面废弃建筑的老位置，然后执事叫格雷迪去停车场。他问格雷迪是否介意帮忙带他的一位乘客提购物袋。格雷迪知道执事的膝盖不好，不能爬楼梯。
I know that he needed my help. So even if I had no money in my pocket, and he needed my help, I would help him. Because I remember the first time I did it for him, the woman had steep-- like, I don't even know, 30, 40 steps up the back house. And that was a little bit of a lug, carrying those groceries up them steep steps.
我知道他需要我的帮助。所以即使我口袋里没钱，如果他需要我的帮助，我也会帮忙。因为我记得我第一次帮他的时候，那位女士有很陡的——我甚至不知道，30、40级台阶进后屋。那是很重的一担，提着杂货爬上那些陡峭的台阶。
Grady figured Deacon was making a cool profit as a jitney driver. He knew other jitneys charged as much as $10 to $20 to ride a couple of blocks. But often, Deacon would give the bulk of the money to Grady. Deacon would pay him just for walking a couple of blocks or going up one flight of stairs, or for just pointing people in his direction.
格雷迪觉得执事作为出租车司机赚了不少钱。他知道其他出租车每走几个街区就收多达10到20美元。但通常，执事会把大部分钱给格雷迪。执事付钱给他，只是因为走了几个街区，或爬了一层楼梯，或者仅仅是指引人们去他的方向。
One time, I told somebody, OK, here's a jitney over here. He gave me $10.
有一次，我告诉某人，好吧，这里有个出租车。他给了我10美元。
None of it made much sense to Grady.
这一切对格雷迪来说都没什么意义。
So it's been numerous times where he gave me $10, where he probably got $15. So I thought to myself, well, how much money could he be making if he's giving me a majority of it?
所以他有很多次给了我10美元，而他可能只收了15美元。所以我心想，如果他把大部分都给了我，他能赚多少钱？
But Grady never asked. He just quietly did the math in his head because he knew Deacon wasn't rich. Patterson worked part-time at Sneakertown, an athletic shoe store across the street from Tops. Grady thought, Deacon must have seen me pushing that shopping cart for miles. Everyone saw me.
但格雷迪从不问。他只是默默地在脑子里算账，因为他知道执事并不富有。帕特森在Tops对面的Sneakertown运动鞋店打零工。格雷迪心想，执事一定见过我推着购物车走几英里。每个人都看见我。
I mean, he knew my situation. So he knew I-- I collected bottles and cans. So well, I'm a week by week money guy. If a day, I don't got no money in my pocket, and then I get some money, that's a beautiful thing, especially for doing something I would have did for free, anyway. So that's probably why, since I think he knew I needed money, that's what he did. He gave me money.
我的意思是，他了解我的情况。所以他知道我——我收集瓶子和罐子。所以我是一个周薪制的人。如果有一天我口袋里没钱，然后我得到了一些钱，那是一件美好的事情，尤其是做了我本来愿意免费做的事情。所以这可能就是为什么，因为我想他知道我需要钱，这就是他所做的。他给了我钱。
That's when Grady realized he wasn't helping Deacon, Deacon was helping him. Deacon wasn't even running a profit-making venture. He was providing a resource for people who needed help. When Grady would ride with Deacon, they'd get to the end of the ride, and the customers would say, how much do I owe you? And Deacon would tell his riders to give whatever your heart desires.
就在那时格雷迪意识到他不是在帮执事，是执事在帮他。执事甚至不是在经营一个盈利项目。他是在为需要帮助的人提供资源。当格雷迪和执事坐车时，他们到了目的地，乘客会问，我欠你多少？而执事会告诉他的乘客随心付。
When I used to hear him say it, I'd be like, whatever they want? Whatever their heart desire? Shoot, it may be $2 their heart may desire. But he would take it.
当我过去听到他这么说，我会心想，随他们心意？随他们的心意？天哪，他们心里想的可能只有2美元。但他也会接受。
And if you're wondering, who does that, Grady wondered the same thing.
如果你想知道是谁会那样做，格雷迪也想过同样的问题。
This older lady, he took her, 1, 2, 3 blocks up. And she kept asking, how much. And he kept telling her how much you can afford. She ended up giving him $10. He gave me $8.
那位老太太，他载她走了1、2、3个街区。她一直问多少钱。他一直告诉她你负担得起就行。她最终给了他10美元。他给了我8美元。
The one thing that Deacon Patterson and Grady had in common is that they were Black men in Buffalo, which also meant that they were subject to the systemic failures of their city. In Buffalo, the Black unemployment rate is nearly twice the White unemployment rate. In Buffalo, more than a third of the Black population lives in poverty. In Buffalo, Black residents are six times more likely to live in an area without a grocery store.
帕特森执事和格雷迪共同点是他们都是布法罗的黑人男子，这也意味着他们都受到城市系统性失败的影响。在布法罗，黑人失业率几乎是白人失业率的两倍。在布法罗，超过三分之一的黑人人口生活在贫困中。在布法罗，黑人居民生活在没有杂货店区域的可能性是其他人的六倍。
Deacon Patterson was just one of the members of this community who took it upon themselves to patch the shoddy social safety net that's supposed to address these problems, problems that should be considered public concerns and solved with public resources. Deacon Patterson helped people because he could see that people needed help.
帕特森执事只是这个社区的一员，他自觉去修补那个本该解决这些问题的拙劣社会安全网，这些本应被视为公共利益并用公共资源解决的问题。帕特森执事帮助人们，因为他能看到人们需要帮助。
On Friday, May 13, Deacon didn't have any work for Grady, so Grady hung around in front of the store. He chatted up the security guard who works the shift before Aaron Salter. He ran into his mother shopping at Tops.
5月13日星期五，执事没有工作让格雷迪做，所以格雷迪就在商店门前晃悠。他跟亚伦·萨尔特换班前的保安聊了天。他碰见他妈妈在Tops购物。
And he noticed the new guy leaving the store. Grady says he approached him, and when the stranger said he was from out of town, that he stopped by the store on his way to a camping trip, Grady says he told him that he has to go see Niagara Falls. The next day, Saturday morning, Grady went to Miss Penny's Plate of Love as usual.
而且他注意到有个新来的人离开了商店。格雷迪说他走过去，当那个陌生人说他是外地人，说他是在去露营的路上在店里停了一下时，格雷迪说他告诉他，你一定要去看看尼亚加拉瀑布。第二天，周六上午，格雷迪像往常一样去了“佩妮女士的爱之盘”。
And I woke up late. So I always would take out the garbage for her because she does a lot in the community. So I went up there late, and I got there about 12:00 or something like that. She finished cleaning up about 2:00.
我醒晚了。所以我总是会帮她倒垃圾，因为她在社区里做了很多事。所以我晚了，大概12点左右到的。她2点左右打扫完。
She had two breakfasts still. And I was like, well, I can find somebody to give it to because I was going to Tops anyway. Because I know it's a lot of people there, and they will want the breakfast.
她还有两份早餐没发出去。我心想，好吧，我可以找人给他们，因为我本来就要去Tops。因为我知道那里有很多人，他们会想要早餐。
Miss Penny told Grady, oh, I have something to get at the store. I'll give you a ride.
佩妮女士告诉格雷迪，噢，我在店里有东西要买。我带你一程。
I dropped him off up on Jefferson, dropped Grady off. And I went to take care of something that I had to. And then--
我把他放在杰斐逊路口，放下了格雷迪。然后我去处理了一些我必须做的事。然后——
She dropped me off at the store. I walked across the street because there was nobody there. And then-- and I'd seen an old guy out there. And then I gave him a breakfast.
她把我放在了商店门口。我走到马路对面，因为那里没人。然后——我看见那里有个老头。然后我给了他一份早餐。
And I walked right next door to Tops. And I gave one of the breakfasts to the guys that were sitting over there. And I noticed the police guard, Aaron Salter's car. He had an old, fancy Cadillac.
我走到Tops隔壁。我把其中一份早餐给了坐在那里的家伙们。我注意到了警察警卫，亚伦·萨尔特的车。他有一辆老式的、豪华的凯迪拉克。
Grady saw Roberta Drury, noticed she had a nice dress on and a lot more groceries than normal. He saw Pearl Young, who had just attended a prayer breakfast. And he saw the Deacon, who had just come from Mr. Love's barbershop, standing outside the store as usual.
格雷迪看见了罗伯塔·德鲁里，注意到她穿着漂亮的裙子，而且杂货比平时多得多。他看见了刚刚参加完祈祷早餐会的珀尔·杨。他还看见执事，刚刚从爱情理发店出来，像往常一样站在店外。
I talked to the old man for a quick second. I bought my drink, walked out. And I thought to myself, you know, I should sit here for a second because I see there's a lot of people out here. Maybe he's having a good day today, and don't really mind too much.
我跟那个老人聊了一小会儿。我买了饮料，走出来。我想，你知道，我应该在这里坐一会儿，因为我看到这里有很多人。也许他今天心情不错，不会太介意。
And it was a beautiful day out, so I walked across the street at the bus stop. And then I opened my drink, and I took a sip out of it. And I heard a big "boom!"
天气很好，所以我走到马路对面的公交车站。然后我打开饮料，喝了一口。然后我听见一声巨响，“砰！”
And then I looked up from where I was sitting at, right across. And I saw this white smoke. And I think I'd seen her fall, the first victim, Roberta.
我从我坐的地方抬头看，就在对面。我看见了白烟。我想我看见她倒下了，第一个受害者，罗伯塔。
Then I seen a guy in camouflage shoot a lady by the door. Then I'd seen him shoot-- I didn't know at the time, but Deacon. Then I see him shoot through the window, and I'm seeing people running. And then I'm just seeing more smoke.
然后我看见一个穿迷彩服的人朝门口的一位女士开枪。然后我看见他开枪——我当时不知道，但那是执事。然后我看见他射穿了窗户，我看见人们在奔跑。然后我只看到更多的烟。
And I'm thinking, OK, maybe the Russians attacked us, and I didn't hear about it on the news. And I'm like, OK, this is crazy. Then I seen Aaron Salters run back into the building. And I seen the guy go in with his gun, rifle. And he's just shooting.
我心想，好吧，也许俄罗斯人攻击了我们，而我在新闻上没听到。我心想，好吧，这太疯狂了。然后我看见亚伦·萨尔特跑回了建筑物。我看见那个人拿着枪，步枪进去了。他就在那儿射击。
And as soon as he went in, I started yelling and screaming for people, because I don't have a cell phone. I started yelling and screaming for people to call the police, the police. Somebody please call the police.
他一进去，我就开始大喊大叫让人们报警，因为我没有手机。我开始大喊大叫让人报警，警察。有人请报警。
And I'm just hearing the ringing from the-- the gunshots. And it was rapid. And it was loud. It was, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
我只听到枪声的响声。那是急促的。那是响亮的。那是，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰。
I think actually, at that point, that my feelings kind of left my body. Because it was the most incredible thing I ever experienced in my life, that people you know, people you don't know, somebody in there shooting random people with this loud, big gun, and white smoke.
我想实际上，就在那一刻，我的感觉好像离开了我的身体。因为这是我一生中经历过的最令人难以置信的事情，你认识的人，你不认识的人，有人在那里用大枪和白烟随机枪杀随机的人。
You know, Grady was calling me, telling me that they shot Deacon. But I didn't want to accept that. So I asked him, Deacon who? And he said-- I said, was it Deacon from my church? And he said, yes.
你知道，格雷迪在给我打电话，告诉我他们枪杀了执事。但我不想接受那个。所以我问他，执事谁？他说——我说，是那个我们教堂的执事吗？他说，是的。
And at that particular time, he talk-- he said, wait. And then he said, they just covered him up. So I knew then Deacon was gone.
就在那一刻，他说，等等。然后他说，他们刚把他盖上了。所以我那时就知道执事走了。
It's been three months since the shooting. Tops has reopened, and the men are back in front of the store, across from the memorial to the 10 lives that were stolen from this community. The car with the silver stripe isn't waiting at Tops, or at the Plate of Love on Saturday mornings.
枪击案已经过去三个月了。Tops重新开业，男人们回到了店前，对面就是纪念这10个被从社区夺走生命的纪念碑。那辆带银色条纹的车不再在Tops等待，或者在周六早上在爱之盘等待。
When I pull into the parking lot, that first vehicle I would see in the parking lot would be Deacon Patterson's vehicle. And I would always park next to him. And to pull up in the parking lot, and his car not be there, that was strange.
当我开进停车场时，我在停车场看到的第一辆车就是帕特森执事的车。我总是会停在他旁边。当开进停车场，他的车不在那儿，那感觉很奇怪。
And to go in, to enter the church through the side door of the parking lot-- and when I would go into the church, I would see Deacon Patterson. So to go into the services and not see him, to come to the Plate of Love and not see him, you know, is a great loss, a great loss.
去进入通过停车场侧门的教堂——当我走进教堂时，我会看到帕特森执事。所以去参加礼拜却没有看到他，去爱之盘却没看到他，你知道，是一个巨大的损失，一个巨大的损失。
That loss is being felt in different places by different people across Buffalo's East Side. Pamela Pritchett no longer sees her mom, Pearl Young, pop up on Facebook, asking, why wasn't I invited? At Garnell Whitfield's Sr.'s nursing home, everyone notices that Mrs. Ruth Whitfield no longer comes every day, bringing gifts for the staff that she picked up thrifting.
这种损失在布法罗东区的不同地方被不同的人感受到。帕梅拉·普里切特不再看到她妈妈，珀尔·杨，跳出Facebook问，“为什么没邀请我？”在加内尔·惠特菲尔德老人的疗养院，每个人都注意到露丝·惠特菲尔德夫人不再每天都来，带着她淘来的给员工的礼物。
When Kayla Jones turned 25 last week, she cried. Normally, her grandmother would be the first person to call her on her birthday.
当凯拉·琼斯上周满25岁时，她哭了。通常，她的祖母会是她生日那天第一个给她打电话的人。
When someone is missing from your daily life because of a racist act of terror, it changes you. It's changed Grady-- Grady, who used to talk to everyone, who had approached a stranger outside Tops the day before the shooting. Grady learned that that person was, of course, the same person who came back the next day and allegedly shot and killed 10 people in front of him, a young white man who traveled to one of the most segregated cities in America determined to kill Black people.
当某人因为这种种族主义恐怖行为而从你的日常生活中消失时，它改变了你。它改变了格雷迪——那个曾经跟每个人说话的格雷迪，他在枪击案前一天曾接近过Tops外的一个陌生人。格雷迪了解到那个人当然就是第二天回来，涉嫌枪杀并杀害了在他面前的10个人的那个人，一个来到美国种族隔离最严重城市之一，决心杀害黑人的年轻白人。
And Grady, the man in front of the store, is still watching. But he sees things different now.
而格雷迪，那个店前的男人，依然在观察。但他现在看到的东西不一样了。
I was at the memorial. And a lady and her husband and her young son-- 18, 19, 20-- I'm talking to them, no problem. I looked at him, and I was scared of him. And I'd seen another young white kid, boy. I was scared of him.
我在纪念碑前。一位女士和她丈夫以及她的小儿子——18、19、20岁——我和他们说话，没问题。我看着他，我很怕他。我又看见了另一个年轻的白人小孩，男孩。我很怕他。
So I have this thing now to where I'm kind of scared of young white boys now. Probably-- well, probably-- definitely from the shooting, for me talking to this kid, and him seeming to be like a regular guy. And I don't even think-- I went to the Tops on Elmwood, this all-white Tops. And then-- it's just-- it's me. I felt like every white person was looking at me.
所以我现在有一种感觉，就是我现在有点怕年轻的白人男孩。可能——好吧，可能——绝对是因为那场枪击案，因为我和这个孩子说话，他看起来像个普通人。我甚至都不觉得——我去过艾尔姆伍德那边的Tops，那是全是白人的Tops。然后——就是——是我自己。我觉得好像每个白人都在盯着我。
Before the shooting, Grady's can-collecting trek took him to neighborhoods all over Buffalo.
枪击案发生前，格雷迪收集罐子的行程带他去了布法罗各地的社区。
Even when-- before this, I would always would be cautious. But I kind of had a break because I was an old Black guy pushing a shopping cart. Maybe nobody would bother him. Now, I mean, they're shooting old people in supermarkets. So yeah, so I don't feel safe in going in no neighborhoods anymore.
即使在——这之前，我总是很谨慎。但我有一种放松，因为我是一个推着购物车的老黑人。也许没人会打扰他。现在，我的意思是，他们在超市枪杀老人。所以是的，所以我觉得在任何社区都不安全了。
So I haven't been able to collect my bottles and cans anymore. Because like I said, I would go on the West Side and North Buffalo. And those are predominantly white neighborhoods. And I would do it at 12:00 at night, 12:00, 1:00, 2:00, 3:00, 4:00, 5:00. I can't take no chance and do that at all.
所以我没法再去收集瓶子和罐子了。因为就像我说的，我会去西区和北布法罗。那些都是以白人为主的社区。我会12点、12点、1点、2点、3点、4点、5点去做。我没法拿任何机会那样做。
And it's kind of a shame because-- well, it ain't kind of a shame, it is a shame because actually, I love collecting bottles and cans. It made me feel like I had a purpose, doing something good for the environment, and also making money, and getting exercise in. I walked 23 miles, made my own time.
这是一种耻辱，因为——好吧，这不是耻辱，这是一件耻辱的事，因为实际上，我喜欢收集瓶子和罐子。它让我觉得自己有一个目标，为环境做了一些好事，也赚了钱，还得到了锻炼。我走了23英里，自己掌握时间。
You know, if I wanted to work, I can work. If I want to work later, I can work later. If I wanted, could go to work earlier. So I felt free in that sense.
你知道，如果我想工作，我可以工作。如果我想晚点工作，我可以晚点工作。如果我想，可以更早去工作。所以我在那方面感到自由。
If the world made sense, Grady would still feel free. If the world made sense, Deacon Patterson's life could serve as a parable about love, charity, or the redemptive quality of grace. But there is a danger in manufacturing meaning out of something so meaningless. There is no way to rationalize the hate that left a huge, gaping hole in an entire community.
如果世界有道理，格雷迪依然会感到自由。如果世界有道理，帕特森执事的一生可以成为一个关于爱、慈善或宽恕的救赎品质的寓言。但从毫无意义的事情中制造意义存在危险。没有任何方法可以合理化那在整个社区留下一个巨大空洞的仇恨。
Then again, if any of this made sense, there'd be no such thing as Black neighborhoods, or poverty, or food deserts, or racial disparities, or senseless violence. If the world made sense, Deacon Heyward Patterson would still be a man in front of a store.
再说一遍，如果这一切有道理，就不会有黑人社区、贫困、食物沙漠、种族差异或毫无意义的暴力。如果世界有道理，海沃德·帕特森执事依然会是店前的那个人。
Michael Harriot writes for TheGrio. And he's the host of TheGrio Daily podcast.
迈克尔·哈里奥特为《TheGrio》写作。他是《TheGrio Daily》播客的主持人。
Our program was produced today by Chana Joffe-Walt and our Executive Editor, Emanuele Berry. The people who put together today's show include Elna Baker, Chris Benderev, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Andrea López Cruzado, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our Managing Editor-- Sarah Abdurrahman. Our Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由Chana Joffe-Walt和我们的执行编辑Emanuele Berry制作。制作今天节目的成员包括Elna Baker, Chris Benderev, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Andrea López Cruzado, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney和Diane Wu。我们的执行主编——Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。
Special thanks to Madison Carter, Sherry Sherrill of Covington Associates Consulting and We Are Women Warriors, Barbara Massey-Mapp, Peter Kramer, Shawn Litster, James Pennington, Valerie Wilcox, Alvina Alston, Jay Rey, and Jerry Urban and WBFO News.
特别感谢Madison Carter, Covington Associates Consulting的Sherry Sherrill和We Are Women Warriors, Barbara Massey-Mapp, Peter Kramer, Shawn Litster, James Pennington, Valerie Wilcox, Alvina Alston, Jay Rey, Jerry Urban和WBFO新闻。
Thanks again to Curtis Lovell, the Buffalo musician you're hearing right now and throughout our show. You can find her on Spotify, iTunes, wherever you get your music. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos, there's lists of favorite shows, there's tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
再次感谢柯蒂斯·洛弗尔，你现在和整个节目中听到的布法罗音乐家。你可以在Spotify, iTunes，任何你获取音乐的地方找到她。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费流媒体收听我们超过750集的档案。还有视频，最喜欢节目的列表，网站上还有很多其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心PRX交付给公共广播电台。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。